At Medcan, we know that life's greatest moments are built on a foundation of good health, from the big milestones to the quiet winds. That's why our annual health assessment offers a physician-led, full-body checkup that provides a clear picture of your health today, and may uncover early signs of conditions like heart disease and cancer. The healthier you means more moments to cherish. Take control of your well-being and book an assessment today. Medcan. Live well for life.
在Medcan，我们深知人生最美好的时刻建立在健康的基础之上，无论是重大的里程碑还是宁静的瞬间。正因如此，我们的年度健康评估提供由医生主导的全身检查，为您呈现当下的健康状况，并可能及早发现心脏病和癌症等疾病的迹象。您越健康，就越能拥有更多值得珍惜的时刻。掌控您的健康，立即预约评估。Medcan，为您的一生健康保驾护航。
Visit medcan.com slash moments to get started. Iran, because of the great leadership of the Shah, is an island of stability in one of the more troubled areas of the world. This is a great tribute to you, your majesty, and to your leadership and to the respect and the admiration and love which your people give to you. We in the United States have no other nation on earth who is closer to us in planning for our mutual military security and there is no leader with whom I have a deeper sense of personal gratitude and personal friendship. On behalf of the people of the United States, I would like to offer a toast at this time. to the great leaders of Iran, the Shah and the Shah Banu, and to the people of Iran, and to the world peace that we hope together we can help to bring.
访问medcan.com/moments开始预约。伊朗，由于沙阿（国王）的英明领导，成为了世界上动荡地区中的一片稳定绿洲。陛下，这是对您、对您的领导力，以及对您的人民给予您的尊重、钦佩和爱戴的崇高敬意。在美国，没有哪个国家比伊朗在规划我们共同的军事安全方面与我们更亲近，也没有哪位领导人让我怀有更深切的个人感激和友谊。在此，我谨代表美国人民提议举杯，敬伊朗伟大的领导人——沙阿和沙阿巴努（王后），敬伊朗人民，并敬我们共同希望能够促成的世界和平。
Now, people listening to that may think that that is an Englishman who can't do a good impression of someone from Georgia, but it isn't. It was actually, Dominic, President Jimmy Carter. And he was toasting the last Shah of Iran, as Americans call it, or as we in Britain call it correctly, Iran. Muhammad Reza Pahlavi and his wife, Empress Farah, the Shah Banu, at a banquet in Iran's capital, Tehran on New Year's Eve, 1977. And Dominic, it is a moment ripe with irony, is it not? It is indeed. It's one of the great ironic moments, not just of the 1970s, but the late 20th century. So this moment when Jimmy Carter is toasting the Shah and the Shah Banu,
现在，听众可能会认为那是一个模仿乔治亚州口音失败的英国人，但事实并非如此。多米尼克，那其实是吉米·卡特总统。他当时正在伊朗首都德黑兰举行的1977年除夕宴会上，向伊朗末代沙阿（美国人这样称呼，而我们在英国则正确地称其为伊朗）穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维及其夫人法拉赫皇后（沙阿巴努）敬酒。多米尼克，这一刻充满了讽刺意味，不是吗？确实如此。这不仅是20世纪70年代，也是整个20世纪末最具有讽刺意味的时刻之一。所以，当吉米·卡特向沙阿和沙阿巴努敬酒时，
the friendship between Iran and the United States, and the stability and the security that Iran offers in the Middle East, this comes just days before the outbreak of a violent revolution that sweeps the Shah from power, and it kicks off the rule of the Ayatollahs who still govern Iran today. Well, Dominic, you say that. We are recording this in early January. I mean, by the time this goes out, who knows what may have happened.
伊朗与美国之间的友谊，以及伊朗在中东所提供的稳定与安全，这一切发生在一场暴力革命爆发的前几天，这场革命将沙阿赶下了台，并开启了至今仍统治着伊朗的阿亚图拉政权。多米尼克，你这么说。我们是在一月初录制这期节目的。我的意思是，等到节目播出时，谁知道会发生什么呢。
That's true because Iran is once again engulfed in street protest, demonstrations, violent repression and so on. The storm clouds of counter-revolution are gathering. There indeed. But to go back to the revolution itself, Jimmy Carter, the man who is standing there giving that toast, he is one of the first and most prominent political victims of this revolution. Because his presidency, pretty extraordinary and strange presidency, even by a very, American standards is consumed by the fires of the Iranian Revolution. So it's an extraordinary story. One of the things that brings Ronald Reagan to power, and one of the advantages of Reagan is
确实如此，因为伊朗再次陷入了街头抗议、示威、暴力镇压等动荡之中。反革命的阴云正在聚集。确实。但回到革命本身，吉米·卡特，那个站在那里敬酒的人，他是这场革命最早、最显著的政治受害者之一。因为他的总统任期——即使以美国标准来看也是非常非凡且奇怪的任期——被伊朗革命的烈火所吞噬。所以这是一个非凡的故事。促成罗纳德·里根上台的原因之一，而里根的优势在于
he's much easier to do an impersonation of. Yes. So just to give people a little sense of the way the rest of history works, I think that was about the 24th take. And if you think, if you have any question marks about Tom's rendition of Jimmy Carter there, let me just emphasize, it was a lot better than the previous 23 takes. Which he sounded very like Shane Warren for a lot of the time. He did. So what we're going to be telling in this series
他更容易模仿。是的。为了让大家了解历史的其余部分是如何运作的，我想那大约是第24次录音。如果你对汤姆模仿吉米·卡特有任何疑问，让我强调一下，这比前23次好多了。因为他之前听起来很像肖恩·沃恩。确实。所以我们在这个系列中要讲述的是
is the story of the fall of the Shah and the rise of the Ayatollahs. The capture of the US embassy in Tehran, this extraordinary moment when 66 Americans were held hostage for 444 days and Jimmy Carter's disastrous attempt Operation Eagle Claw
沙阿倒台和阿亚图拉崛起的故事。德黑兰美国大使馆被占领，这是66名美国人被扣为人质长达444天的非凡时刻，以及吉米·卡特灾难性的尝试——“鹰爪行动”
to rescue them, which ended in disaster and tragedy. And Dominic, again, just to say, we are recording this in the immediate aftermath of the US raid on Caracas, which was, in military terms, an incredible success. And I guess what happens in Iran with Carter is the polar opposite. It's an absolute disaster. It is. So it's an incredibly dramatic story, but one that has really, really serious repercussions. So first of all, this story, what happens in Iran in the late 1970s completely overturns the diplomatic chessboard of the Middle East. It turns Iran from one of America's closest regional allies into an implacable opponent, an opponent that today is making drones used by the Russians in Ukraine, for example. And secondly, and I know this is something that you find fascinating, Tom, this is the story of the Islamic Revolution. Arguably, I would say, the only global revolution comparable with the French and the Russian
营救他们，最终以灾难和悲剧告终。多米尼克，再次说明，我们是在美国突袭卡拉卡斯之后立即录制的，从军事角度来看，那是一次令人难以置信的成功。我想伊朗发生的卡特事件与之截然相反。那是一场绝对的灾难。确实。所以这是一个极其戏剧性的故事，但却有着非常、非常严重的后果。首先，这个故事，即20世纪70年代末伊朗发生的事情，彻底颠覆了中东的外交棋局。它将伊朗从美国最亲密的地区盟友之一变成了不共戴天的对手，一个今天正在制造俄罗斯在乌克兰使用的无人机的对手。其次，我知道这是你非常着迷的事情，汤姆，这是伊斯兰革命的故事。我认为，这可以说是唯一能与法国和俄国
revolutions in terms of its dramatic cultural and political consequences. I would say definitely. I mean, it fires a starting gun on the kind of the wave of Islamic militancy that has shaken the world since 1979. So a lot to talk about. But let's start with those two men in Tehran on New Year's Eve, 1977. So they are in the Naivaritan Palace, which is in the northern foothills on the edge of Tehran. And Tehran, to give people a sense, it's the capital of Iran. it's a city that had changed enormously in the 20 years before Jimmy Carter visited.
革命在戏剧性的文化和政治后果方面相提并论的全球性革命。我绝对同意。我的意思是，它打响了自1979年以来震撼世界的伊斯兰激进主义浪潮的第一枪。所以有很多要谈的。但让我们从1977年除夕夜在德黑兰的那两个人开始。他们当时在尼亚瓦兰宫，位于德黑兰边缘的北部山麓。为了让大家有个概念，德黑兰是伊朗的首都。在吉米·卡特访问之前的20年里，这座城市发生了巨大的变化。
So it had been transformed by billions of dollars in new oil money, new housing blocks, new factories, and above all, new people. So in the 1940s, the end of the Second World War, Tehran had half a million people. In 1977, when Carter went, it had almost 5 million people. And that stratospheric growth, that single fact, in some ways, lies at the heart of today's episode, the extraordinary change in the kind of social, economic makeup of Tehran and indeed of Iran generally. I would say that of all the cities I've ever been to, Tehran is the one that seems the least capable of coping, say, with traffic. The traffic there, I mean, unbelievable, and you have vast lanes with no traffic lights, no way of crossing it. The whole infrastructure is buckling at the seams.
它被数十亿美元的新石油资金、新的住宅区、新的工厂，最重要的是，新的人口所改变。因此，在20世纪40年代，即第二次世界大战结束时，德黑兰有50万人口。1977年卡特去的时候，它已经有近500万人口了。那种平流层般的增长，这一单一事实，在某种程度上构成了今天这一集的核心，即德黑兰乃至整个伊朗在社会、经济构成上的非凡变化。我想说，在我去过的所有城市中，德黑兰似乎是最无法应对交通问题的。那里的交通，我的意思是，令人难以置信，你有宽阔的车道却没有红绿灯，根本无法横穿。整个基础设施都在崩溃的边缘。
The seams buckle, you know what I mean. And I guess that this is a legacy of the kind of the great big. boom in the 60s and 70s. Exactly, which we'll come to. So of all the people in Tehran in 1977, the most celebrated and powerful was the man that Carter was toasting that night, the host. And that's
接缝处在崩裂，你知道我的意思。我想这是一种60年代和70年代大繁荣的遗产。正是如此，我们稍后会谈到。所以，在1977年德黑兰的所有人中，最著名和最有权势的就是卡特那天晚上敬酒的那个人，也就是主人。那就是
Mohamed Reza Pahlavi, who is the king of kings and light of the Aryans, the Shah of Iran. And let's give people a sense of his character. He was born in 1919 to an army officer called Rezar Pahlavi in a land that was then called
穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维，万王之王，雅利安人的光芒，伊朗沙阿。让我们来了解一下他的性格。他出生于1919年，父亲是一位名叫礼萨·巴列维的军官，出生在一个当时在西方被称为
in the West, Persia. Persia, of course, a very ancient country, not so much a nation as a civilization in itself, multi-ethnic, multilingual. Of course, the one thing that people get wrong about Persia and Iran is they think that they, I mean, people would often call them Arabs. They're not Arabs.
波斯的土地上。波斯，当然是一个非常古老的国家，与其说是一个民族，不如说是一种文明本身，多民族、多语言。当然，人们对波斯和伊朗最大的误解是他们认为，我的意思是，人们经常称他们为阿拉伯人。他们不是阿拉伯人。
It's the one thing they're absolutely not. It's very important to Iranians. They're not an Arab country. What's also very important, it was the only country in the world that had adopted a particular kind of Islam, Shia or Shiite Islam as its state religion. And we will come back to this because this question about Shiaism or Shia Islam lies at the center of the Iranian revolution. It absolutely does.
这是他们绝对不是的一点。这对伊朗人来说非常重要。他们不是一个阿拉伯国家。同样非常重要的是，它是世界上唯一一个采用特定伊斯兰教派——什叶派伊斯兰教作为国教的国家。我们将回到这一点，因为关于什叶派或什叶派伊斯兰教的问题是伊朗革命的核心。绝对是这样。
And of course people will think of Iran as an Islamic country, which it completely is. But just to emphasize on the ancient roots of the dynamic in Iran in this episode. I mean, it is incredibly ancient. So Farsi, the predominant language in Iran. is descended from the language spoken by the first great rulers of Persia, Cyrus and Darius the Great and people like that. And that framework of a monarchy and a priesthood, which you see in 20th century Iran and which is so fundamental to the dynamics of the Iranian Revolution, I mean, that ultimately reaches back before the coming of Islam all the way back again to
当然，人们会认为伊朗是一个伊斯兰国家，它确实完全是。但只是为了强调本集中伊朗动态的古老根源。我的意思是，它极其古老。所以波斯语，伊朗的主要语言，源自波斯第一批伟大的统治者，居鲁士大帝、大流士大帝等人所说的语言。而你在20世纪伊朗所看到的君主制和神职人员的框架，以及对伊朗革命动态如此根本的框架，我的意思是，那最终可以追溯到伊斯兰教到来之前，一直追溯到
the time of Cyrus and Darius. And the concept of monarchy is at least, least as fundamental to the historical makeup of Iran as the idea of a kind of a cleracy. So the great epic of Iran for Daoese, Shana Mae. I mean, it's literally the book of kings. So when the Shah stands up there, he is, I think, correctly conscious of himself as the air of thousands of years of rule by monarchs. Right. Well, let's talk about monarchs. So let's talk about Muhammad Rizhar Pahlavi.
居鲁士和大流士的时代。君主制的概念至少与神权政治的概念一样，是伊朗历史构成中不可或缺的一部分。所以伊朗的伟大史诗《列王纪》。我的意思是，它字面上就是国王之书。所以当沙阿站在那里时，我认为他正确地意识到自己是数千年来君主统治的继承人。好吧，让我们谈谈君主。让我们谈谈穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维。
So in his lifetime, I said he was born in 1919. In his lifetime, indeed that of his father, Persia had fallen prey to a series of rival colonial empires, specifically Russia and Britain. And that was turbocharged in 2008 when the British struck oil. And that was the moment that created the Anglo-Persian oil company, which we all know much better as BP. So in the First World War, Persia was occupied by the Russians and the British. And after the First World War, it fell into total chaos. So in 1921, Muhammad's father Rezaa Pahlavi staged a coup with British support and he ends up becoming Rezar Shah.
在他的一生中，我说过他出生于1919年。在他的一生中，实际上在他父亲的一生中，波斯沦为了一系列相互竞争的殖民帝国的猎物，特别是俄罗斯和英国。而在2008年（注：此处原文有误，应为1908年）英国发现石油时，这种情况被加速了。那一刻创造了英波石油公司，也就是我们更熟悉的BP。所以在一战中，波斯被俄罗斯和英国占领。一战后，它陷入了彻底的混乱。因此，在1921年，穆罕默德的父亲礼萨·巴列维在英国的支持下发动了政变，最终成为了礼萨·沙阿。
He takes the throne himself, which means that Mohammed becomes crown prince at the age of just two years old. Now, Rezar Shah is a very, very formidable man. His son said he was one of the most frightening men he ever met and he was definitely not a loving father. So he supposedly thought that if he was too kind to his own. son, then it would mean that his son became gay. So he didn't show him too much affection. And Muhammad grew up as the absolutely classic textbook, anxious, shy, reserved son of an overbearing, terrifying military father. So very, very Alexis and Peter the Great for people who remember that series. And Mohammed was sent off to a Swiss boarding school. He became a massive Francophile at
他自己登上了王位，这意味着穆罕默德在两岁时就成为了王储。现在，礼萨·沙阿是一个非常、非常可怕的人。他的儿子说他是有史以来最令人生畏的人之一，而且他绝对不是一个慈爱的父亲。所以他据称认为，如果他对自己的儿子太好，那意味着他的儿子会变成同性恋。所以他没有表现出太多的爱。穆罕默德成长为一个典型的、焦虑的、害羞的、内向的、被一个专横、可怕的军事父亲所压制的儿子。所以对于记得那个系列的人来说，非常非常像亚历克西斯和彼得大帝。穆罕默德被送往瑞士寄宿学校。他成为了一个狂热的亲法派，
the school, which he remained all his life. And in fact, because he was sent off. He was sent off to a Swiss boarding school. He became a massive Francophile at the school, which he remained all his life. And in fact, because he associates Iran with his father and because he goes off to boarding school in the West, he is always something of a moderniser and a westernizer. And indeed, a secularizer, which as we will see, is something of a problem. Yeah, and he loves very expensive French food, doesn't he? Which will feature later in this show. Well, how should I put this? He likes French courtesans, I think it's the best way of putting it. So in 1941, Persia, which his father, Rezaar has renamed, or he has basically asked people abroad, stop calling it Persia, please. We don't call it Persia. We call it the land of the Aryans,
在学校里，他终其一生都保持着这种倾向。事实上，因为他被送走了。他被送往瑞士寄宿学校。他成为了一个狂热的亲法派，在学校里，他终其一生都保持着这种倾向。事实上，因为他将伊朗与他的父亲联系在一起，而且因为他去西方的寄宿学校，他一直是一个现代化者和西化者。而且确实，是一个世俗化者，正如我们将看到的，这有点问题。是的，他喜欢非常昂贵的法国食物，不是吗？这将在本节目的后面部分出现。好吧，我该怎么说呢？我想最好的说法是他喜欢法国交际花。所以1941年，波斯，他父亲礼萨重新命名，或者他基本上要求国外的人，请停止称它为波斯。我们不叫它波斯。我们称它为雅利安人的土地，
its ancient name, which is Iran. So Persia or Iran is occupied once again by the British and the Soviets to stop the Nazis getting its oil. And the British thought that Rezar-Palavi was too pro-German and they made him abdicate in favour of his son, who's now 21. This kind of meddling by the British in Iranian politics is such a feature of 19th and early 20th century history, isn't it? That even now in the 21st century, the Iranians are still prone to thinking that Britain lurks behind everything wrong. They do. It's very flattering for us because whenever anything happens, the Iranians assume that the British are controlling everything. So it's notoriety way above our station now.
它的古老名字，即伊朗。所以波斯或伊朗再次被英国和苏联占领，以阻止纳粹获得其石油。英国人认为礼萨·巴列维太亲德了，他们让他退位，转而支持他21岁的儿子。这种英国人对伊朗政治的干预是19世纪和20世纪初历史的一个显著特征，不是吗？以至于即使在21世纪，伊朗人仍然倾向于认为英国潜伏在所有错误的事情背后。他们确实如此。这对我们来说非常受宠若惊，因为每当发生什么事情时，伊朗人就假设英国人在控制一切。所以这是一种远高于我们现在地位的恶名。
Completely. We're punching above our weight in the Iranian imagination. So at 21 years old, Mohammed Rezaa Pahlavi is the new Shah of Iran. He has a double taint. So first of all, he's the son of a usurper who seized the throne in a British back coup in 1921. And he only got the throne himself 20 years later because the British basically gave it to him. So there's this impression of being a foreign puppet. And this is confirmed a decade later in one of the most controversial, if not the most controversial, moments in Iranian history. So in 1953, Iran had democratically elected prime minister called Mohamed Modadek, who's this very kind of wily old bird, this experienced, reformist,
完全是。我们在伊朗人的想象中分量过重了。所以21岁时，穆罕默德·礼萨·巴列维成为了伊朗的新沙阿。他有两个污点。首先，他是1921年在英国支持的政变中夺取王位的篡位者的儿子。而他自己20年后才得到王位，因为英国人基本上把它给了他。所以有一种作为外国傀儡的印象。而这一点在十年后伊朗历史上最具争议的时刻之一得到了证实。所以1953年，伊朗有一位民主选举产生的总理，名叫穆罕默德·摩萨台，他是一个非常狡猾的老狐狸，这位经验丰富的、改革派的、
liberal politician. And he has pledged that he will nationalize this Anglo-Persian oil company BP. And the British, understandably, I suppose, they hate this idea because they want to keep all the money for themselves. And they basically persuade the CIA to organize a coup. And there's a coup. About 250 people are killed. Mossadegh is toppled and he's put under house arrest for the rest of his life. Now the Shah, who's the sort of, you know, he's the figurehead of Iran. He knew about this coup. He kind of supported it. He spent most of it hiding in a hotel in Rome, but then coming back to Iran. And a lot of people in the Iranian elite conclude at the end of 1953, you know, the Shah, he's basically a complete coward and a wimp, and he is a Western
自由派政治家。他承诺将英波石油公司BP国有化。而英国人，我理解，他们讨厌这个想法，因为他们想把所有的钱都留给自己。他们基本上说服了中央情报局组织了一场政变。政变发生了。大约250人被杀。摩萨台被推翻，并被软禁了余生。现在沙阿，他是那种，你知道，他是伊朗的象征。他知道这场政变。他某种程度上支持它。他大部分时间都躲在罗马的一家酒店里，但后来回到了伊朗。1953年底，伊朗精英阶层中的许多人得出结论，你知道，沙阿，他基本上是一个彻底的懦夫和软蛋，他是一个西方
puppet, because he did nothing to resist this coup. But then from the late 1950s onwards, Mostek on, the Shah starts to assert himself. He becomes more than a figurehead. So like his father, he is a moderniser. So both of them, Rizapalovia, a classic kind of military man of them into war years who tried to westernize and modernize Iran, his son is the same. And we'll talk a little bit more in the second half about the political and implications of this, but let's just concentrate on Muhammad and his character. By the 1960s, he is developing a personality cult. His courteous treat him as a demigod. He starts to see himself as the heir to the Great Kings of the past, people like Cyrus the Great. So Cyrus is the founder
傀儡，因为他没有做任何事情来抵抗这场政变。但从20世纪50年代末开始，摩萨台之后，沙阿开始主张自己。他变得不仅仅是一个象征。所以像他父亲一样，他是一个现代化者。所以他们两个，礼萨·巴列维，典型的战间期军人，试图西化和现代化伊朗，他的儿子也是一样。我们将在下半部分更多地谈论这方面的政治影响，但让我们专注于穆罕默德和他的性格。到了20世纪60年代，他正在发展一种个人崇拜。他的朝臣把他当作半神来对待。他开始把自己视为过去伟大国王的继承人，像居鲁士大帝那样的人。所以居鲁士是
of the Persian monarchy. I suppose the great advantage that the Shah has over other would-be dictatorial figures in the mid-20th century is that he does have this incredible historical legacy to draw on. Exactly. And he does with gusto. They put up posters every He's got this classic kind of 1950s, 1960s dictator vibe, so he wears a military uniform and enormous sunglasses. You see, I think that's a mistake. I think if he'd gone for the full long beard, as worn by dress, great. He might have cut a better figure. I like a dictator in sunglasses, to be honest.
波斯君主制的创始人。我想沙阿相对于20世纪中期其他潜在的独裁人物的巨大优势在于，他确实有这种令人难以置信的历史遗产可以利用。正是如此。而且他兴致勃勃地利用了这一点。他们到处张贴海报。他有一种典型的20世纪50年代、60年代独裁者的氛围，所以他穿着军装，戴着巨大的太阳镜。你看，我认为那是一个错误。我认为如果他留起像居鲁士大帝那样的长胡子，他可能会塑造一个更好的形象。老实说，我喜欢戴太阳镜的独裁者。
I'd wear them myself if I was a dictator, but there you go. The thing is that actually behind the scenes, he's still actually a very shy and sullen man and very reserved and timid. But in the West, he becomes a real celebrity. So Western visitors think he's very polished and very impressive. The gossip columns are full of, you know, he speaks English and French fluently. He goes skiing in Saint-Morritz. He plays tennis on the French Riviera. He's the kind of person who, in an alternative universe, would have a cameo in an early Pink Panther film or something.
如果我是独裁者，我自己也会戴，但就是这样。问题是，实际上在幕后，他仍然是一个非常害羞和阴郁的人，非常内向和胆小。但在西方，他成为了一个真正的名人。所以西方游客认为他非常优雅且令人印象深刻。八卦专栏里到处都是，你知道，他英语和法语说得很流利。他在圣莫里茨滑雪。他在法国里维埃拉打网球。他是一个在平行宇宙中会在早期的《粉红豹》电影中客串的人。
He would. He's a slight kind of suave good looks of James Mason. Yeah, David Niven or somebody. David Niven, that kind of vibe, hasn't he? That's exactly the vibe for the Shah. And, you know, as befitting. a sort of 1960s celebrity, he has a taste for the finer things in life. So in 1967, he elevates himself to the title of the original Persian kings, king of kings, Shah and Shah, and he has a new coronation,
他会。他有一种詹姆斯·梅森那种温文尔雅的帅气。是的，大卫·尼文或者某个人。大卫·尼文，那种氛围，不是吗？这正是沙阿的氛围。而且，正如一个20世纪60年代的名人所应有的那样，他有品味，喜欢生活中更美好的事物。所以1967年，他将自己提升为原始波斯国王的头衔，万王之王，沙阿之沙，他举行了新的加冕典礼，
and he has a solid gold scepter, and he has a crown with thousands and thousands of diamonds. Then in 1971, one of the most famous parties in history, he throws this incredible kind of blowout to mark the 2,500th anniversary of the foundation of the Persian monarchy. And where does he have this, Tom? Do you want to tell us? Well, he has it at Persepolis, which is the great city of the ancient Persian kings burnt by Alexander the Great, and which is extraordinary place to visit. But as you visit it, you go past the kind of rusting remains of the tent poles that had
他有一根纯金权杖，他有一顶镶嵌着成千上万颗钻石的皇冠。然后在1971年，历史上最著名的派对之一，他举办了这种令人难以置信的狂欢，以纪念波斯君主制建立2500周年。他在哪里举办的，汤姆？你想告诉我们吗？好吧，他在波斯波利斯举办的，那是被亚历山大大帝烧毁的古代波斯国王的伟大城市，是一个参观起来非常非凡的地方。但当你参观它时，你会经过那种生锈的帐篷杆残骸，
provided this amazing kind of jamboree for people Dominic who had come from across the world, hadn't they? So he had all kinds of glamorous figures. Chichesco from Romania, Mabutu, Imelda Marcos, and perhaps the most sinister figure of all, Princess Anne. Yeah, yeah, I mean, people say, what's your dream historical dinner party? I mean, the Shah's had it, you know? Tito, Imelda Marcos, brilliant. And famously they have the food is flown in from Paris by Maxim's. Yes, Maxim's to Paris and all this sort of Chateau Lafitte, Rothschild and whatnot flown in as well. So incredible.
多米尼克，这些帐篷杆为来自世界各地的人们提供了这种令人惊叹的狂欢，不是吗？所以他有各种各样的迷人人物。罗马尼亚的齐奥塞斯库、蒙博托、伊梅尔达·马科斯，也许最阴险的人物是安妮公主。是的，是的，我的意思是，人们说，你梦想的历史晚宴是什么样的？我的意思是，沙阿已经举办过了，你知道吗？铁托、伊梅尔达·马科斯，太棒了。而且众所周知，食物是由巴黎的马克西姆餐厅空运过来的。是的，巴黎的马克西姆餐厅，所有这些拉菲酒庄、罗斯柴尔德酒庄之类的东西也都是空运过来的。所以令人难以置信。
And this is symptomatic of a sort of wider glitz and glamour and corruption of the Shah's court. So by the early 70s he's got multiple palaces. He's got a countryhouse in England. He's got a country house in Switzerland. He has a palace just for his mistresses who are either escorts flown in from Paris or Luftanzer Air stewardesses. his half-sister is taking millions of dollars in kickbacks. The bloke who books his escorts, is given the caviar export monopoly.
这是沙阿宫廷那种更广泛的浮华、魅力和腐败的征兆。所以到了70年代初，他有多个宫殿。他在英国有一栋乡间别墅。他在瑞士有一栋乡间别墅。他有一个专门为他的情妇准备的宫殿，她们要么是从巴黎空运来的伴游，要么是汉莎航空的空姐。他的同父异母的妹妹正在收取数百万美元的回扣。预订他伴游的家伙，被授予了鱼子酱出口垄断权。
And actually, it's sometimes suggested that a lot of this is kind of Islamic Revolution propaganda. Basically, the Ayatollah's massively exaggerated how corrupt the Shah's court was. But after the Shah's fall, the British Foreign Secretary at the time, David Owen, commissioned an internal report. And this report, British Foreign Office's
而且实际上，有时有人建议这其中很多是某种伊斯兰革命的宣传。基本上，阿亚图拉大大夸大了沙阿宫廷的腐败程度。但在沙阿倒台后，当时的英国外交大臣大卫·欧文委托了一份内部报告。这份报告，英国外交部的
Port basically said it was really corrupt and the Shah himself was taking massive bribes on defence contracts. I mean it's basically it's petrodollars, isn't it? And this is the kind of stuff that oil shakes are going to be doing after the oil shock. So, I mean, it's completely believable. Oh, totally it is. And the oil is obviously a massive part of this story. So the Shah liked having money and in the 70s he gets a lot more of it because in autumn
报告基本上说它确实非常腐败，沙阿本人在国防合同上收取了巨额贿赂。我的意思是，这基本上是石油美元，不是吗？这就是石油酋长们在石油冲击后要做的事情。所以，我的意思是，这完全是可信的。哦，完全是。而且石油显然是这个故事的重要组成部分。所以沙阿喜欢有钱，在70年代他得到了更多，因为在1973年秋天
1973 after the opaque oil shock in which he was a key player, the price of oil almost quad. rupled. And Iran was the world's second biggest oil exporter. So this means the Shah has this colossal windfall and now he really can make Iran great again. And he can fulfill his dream. So his big sponsors by this point, by the 70s, are not the British. They are the Americans. All through the post-war years, the Americans have backed the Shah as a key ally against Soviet expansion into the Persian Gulf, which is one of their big fears. The CIA has been funding and training his secret police, which is called Savak. And Savak had a pretty grisly reputation for torturing their opponents, but torturing dissidents.
欧佩克石油冲击之后，他是其中的关键参与者，石油价格几乎翻了四倍。而伊朗是世界第二大石油出口国。所以这意味着沙阿有了这种巨大的意外之财，现在他真的可以让伊朗再次伟大。他可以实现他的梦想。所以到这个时候，到70年代，他的大赞助人不是英国人。他们是美国人。在整个战后岁月里，美国人一直支持沙阿，将其作为对抗苏联向波斯湾扩张的关键盟友，这是他们最大的恐惧之一。中央情报局一直在资助和训练他的秘密警察，即萨瓦克。而萨瓦克在折磨对手、折磨异见人士方面有着相当恐怖的名声。
So there's a lot of stuff with acid and cattle prods. It's very kind of 1970s, Paraguay or something. And are they particularly targeting poets, which is the big thing in South America, isn't it? Do you know what? They're not, I mean, not as much as you would think, actually. I think it's mainly sort of it's sort of dissident professors and leftists of various kinds
所以有很多关于酸液和电击棒的东西。这非常像20世纪70年代的巴拉圭之类的。他们是否特别针对诗人，这是南美洲的大事，不是吗？你知道吗？他们没有，我的意思是，实际上没有你想象的那么多。我想这主要是某种异见教授和各种各样的左派
but I know you've got it in for poets Tom but actually no I haven't I haven't and that is a plus mark for the Shah and probably reflects the ancient tradition of Persian poetry Yeah maybe and the CIA you know The CIA had poets on their books So the CIA supported American poetry
但我知道你对诗人有意见，汤姆，但实际上没有，我没有，这对沙阿来说是一个加分项，可能反映了波斯诗歌的古老传统。是的，也许，而且中央情报局，你知道，中央情报局有诗人名单。所以中央情报局支持美国诗歌
Oh it's so complicated isn't it Exactly I think if you're a Chilean or Argentine poet I think the 70s a bad decade. Yeah. But if you're an Iranian one, it's better. Maybe a bit better, I don't know. So Henry Kissinger and Richard Nixon,
哦，这太复杂了，不是吗？正是如此，我认为如果你是一个智利或阿根廷诗人，我认为70年代是一个糟糕的十年。是的。但如果你是一个伊朗诗人，情况会好一点。也许好一点，我不知道。所以亨利·基辛格和理查德·尼克松，
who were in charge of American foreign policy in the early 70s, see Iran as an absolutely central player in their anti-communist alliance system. In 1972, Nixon went to Tehran, and he explicitly said to the Shah, you're going to hear a lot of winging from weedy liberals. Please do not listen to this. You are our man. And if you want weapons, we will give you weapons.
他们在70年代初负责美国外交政策，将伊朗视为其反共联盟体系中绝对的核心参与者。1972年，尼克松去了德黑兰，他明确地对沙阿说，你会听到很多软弱的自由派的抱怨。请不要听这些。你是我们的人。如果你想要武器，我们会给你武器。
And the Shah said, brilliant. this is what I'm going to spend my old money on. And in the next six years, he spent $12 billion on all these jet fighters and destroyers and submarines. It was one of the biggest arms sprees in history. He bought more chieftain tanks from the British than the British themselves had in their own army. Just this colossal amount.
沙阿说，太棒了。这就是我要花石油钱的地方。在接下来的六年里，他花了120亿美元购买所有这些喷气式战斗机、驱逐舰和潜艇。这是历史上最大的军备采购狂潮之一。他从英国购买的酋长式坦克比英国军队自己拥有的还要多。只是这种巨大的数量。
Now, other American regional allies thought this was mad. The Saudi oil minister said to the Americans in 1975, the Shah was a megalomaniac, He's highly unstable And if you don't recognise this There must be something wrong With your powers of observation But Dominant, just to say
现在，其他美国地区盟友认为这太疯狂了。沙特石油部长在1975年对美国人说，沙阿是一个自大狂，他高度不稳定，如果你不认识到这一点，你的观察力一定有问题。但多米尼克，只是想说
I mean the Arabs have always hated And feared the Iranians And Saddam Hussein Who is in Iraq And you know prominent leader there Of the Bartists He had this famous phrase Which he was one of his favourites
我的意思是，阿拉伯人一直憎恨并恐惧伊朗人，而萨达姆·侯赛因，他在伊拉克，你知道，那里的杰出领导人，复兴党人，他有这句名言，这是他最喜欢的名言之一
There are three whom God should not have created Flies Jews and Persians God that's poor from Saddam Hussein Isn't that disappointing It has to be said that the Iran Iranians turn that on its head, and they say that there are three things that God should not have created, flies, Jews and Arabs. So it goes two ways. Yeah. So the Shah has very much come to believe his own publicity. There was an observer journalist called Gavin Young, who went
有三种人是上帝不应该创造的：苍蝇、犹太人和波斯人。天哪，萨达姆·侯赛因说得太差劲了。这不是很令人失望吗？必须说，伊朗人把这一点反过来了，他们说上帝不应该创造三种东西：苍蝇、犹太人和阿拉伯人。所以它是双向的。是的。所以沙阿非常相信自己的宣传。有一位观察家杂志的记者名叫加文·杨，他去
to interview him in the mid-70s. He was shocked how arrogant the Shah had become. The Shah said to him, you know, we're going to be top nation. We're going to be such a great country. In 20 years, we'll be ahead of the United States. Now, we are the masters with our our money and our former masters are our slaves. Well, the Shah and Shah, King of Kings. Yeah, punchy from the Shah. Now, mention of the Americans brings us to his guest at that New Year's Eve banquet. And this is the person who you've ventriloquized so magnificently, the 39th president
在70年代中期采访他。他对沙阿变得如此傲慢感到震惊。沙阿对他说，你知道，我们将成为顶级国家。我们将成为一个伟大的国家。20年后，我们将领先于美国。现在，我们是拥有石油钱的主人，而我们以前的主人是我们的奴隶。好吧，万王之王。是的，沙阿的话很有力。现在，提到美国人让我们想起了他在那个除夕宴会上的客人。这就是你模仿得如此精彩的那个人，第39任总统
of the United States, James Earl Carter Jr., Jimmy Carter. And Jimmy Carter, what an extraordinary man he is. I think it's, even by the standards of today's president, it's hard to examine. exaggerate what an unlikely president Jimmy Carter is. So Carter was born in 1924 to unimprovably a peanut farmer in Plains, Georgia, in this absolutely sleepy, backward kind of rural hamlet. And Carter was very self-improving. He went to the Naval Academy in Annapolis, and then he got a job as an engineer on the US nuclear submarine program. And Carter had a very, very distinctive personality. So he's incredibly conscientious.
美国总统，詹姆斯·厄尔·卡特二世，吉米·卡特。而吉米·卡特，他是一个多么非凡的人。我认为，即使以今天总统的标准来看，也很难夸大吉米·卡特是一个多么不可能的总统。所以卡特出生于1924年，出生在乔治亚州平原镇的一个花生农场，在一个绝对沉睡、落后的农村小村庄。卡特非常积极进取。他去了安纳波利斯的美国海军学院，然后在美国核潜艇计划中找到了一份工程师的工作。卡特有着非常、非常独特的个性。所以他极其认真。
He's incredibly hardworking. He's an autodidact. He's not a tremendous laugh. He's a bit of a loner. He's got no close friends. He's very moralistic. He's very competitive. He's very stubborn.
他极其勤奋。他是一个自学者。他不是一个特别爱笑的人。他有点孤独。他没有亲密的朋友。他非常道德化。他非常有竞争力。他非常固执。
He's the kind of person who basically comes home. He's like a sort of character from an improving 19th century manual. He comes home late at night. He probably got up to pray first thing in the morning. Then went to the nuclear submarine. Then he comes home and then he learns Spanish in the evening. That is Jimmy. Garter's vibe. The praying really kicks in a bit later, doesn't it? It does, yeah. But I imagine right
他基本上是那种回家的人。他就像一个来自19世纪励志手册中的角色。他深夜回家。他可能一大早就起来祈祷。然后去了核潜艇。然后他回家，晚上学习西班牙语。这就是吉米·卡特的氛围。祈祷确实是在稍后才开始的，不是吗？确实，是的。但我想象从
from the beginning he's a great man for a cardigan. Totally he is, yeah. I cannot imagine Donald Trump wearing a cardigan. And a plaid shirt, he's very plaid shirt. He loves a plaid shirt, yes. So Carter's father died in 1953. He came back to Plains and he took over the family peanut farm. And he was very good at peanut farming and he was made a great success of it. He modernised it and he moved into local politics and he ran for Congress in 1966 and he lost. And he's a Democrat. And he's a Democrat, isn't he? And he's a Democrat. Like, you have to be in the South at this point. You absolutely have to be to get anywhere. And he lost. And he had this massive existential crisis. He probably sank into depression after he lost. It was the first time he lost anything. And he turned to God and was born again. And later on, when he ran for president, everybody basically north of the Mason-Dixon line laughed at Carter about this. And they wrote all these articles, The Time magazine had a huge cover calling him a weirdo and stuff. But this was because people in New York and Washington didn't understand. that in Georgia, in the Baptist world of rural Georgia, being born again was nothing outlandish. It was absolutely, you know, I wouldn't say it was standard, but it was common.
一开始他就是一个非常喜欢穿开衫的人。完全是，是的。我无法想象唐纳德·特朗普穿开衫。还有格子衬衫，他非常喜欢格子衬衫。他喜欢格子衬衫，是的。所以卡特的父亲在1953年去世了。他回到平原镇，接管了家庭花生农场。他在花生种植方面非常出色，并取得了巨大的成功。他实现了现代化，并进入了地方政治，他在1966年竞选国会议员，但他输了。而且他是民主党人。而且他是民主党人，不是吗？而且他是民主党人。就像，你必须在那个时候的南方。你绝对必须是，才能有所作为。但他输了。他经历了巨大的存在主义危机。他在输掉比赛后可能陷入了抑郁。这是他第一次输掉任何东西。他转向了上帝并重生了。后来，当他竞选总统时，梅森-迪克森线以北的所有人基本上都因为这件事嘲笑卡特。他们写了所有这些文章，《时代》杂志甚至用巨大的封面称他为怪人等等。但这仅仅是因为纽约和华盛顿的人不明白，在乔治亚州，在乔治亚州农村的浸信会世界里，重生并不是什么离奇的事情。这绝对是，你知道，我不会说它是标准的，但它是常见的。
Yeah, and I mean, in view of what is going to happen in 1979 and through the 80s, actually the last laugh is on them because they haven't recognised that religion is going to become an expression of the modern. Quite right. That actually Carter is not a backward-looking figure, as he was often treated in the 70s. he is a forward-looking one. So anyway, he runs again for office in 1970. Again, a very forward-looking thing. He runs as a populist.
是的，我的意思是，鉴于1979年以及80年代将要发生的事情，实际上笑到最后的是他们，因为他们没有认识到宗教将成为现代的一种表达方式。完全正确。实际上卡特并不是一个向后看的形象，正如他在70年代经常被对待的那样。他是一个向前看的人。所以无论如何，他在1970年再次竞选公职。同样，这是一个非常向前看的事情。他以民粹主义者的身份竞选。
And he ran against a man called Carl Sanders, Democrat, establishment figure. And Carter painted him as the sort of puppet of the country club bigwigs. He called him Cufflings Carl. So that is quite Trump. Yeah, of course. Jimmy Carter's populism is really, really interesting.
他与一个名叫卡尔·桑德斯的人竞争，他是民主党建制派人物。卡特把他描绘成乡村俱乐部大人物的傀儡。他称他为“袖扣卡尔”。所以这很像特朗普。是的，当然。吉米·卡特的民粹主义真的、真的很有趣。
It's southern populism. It's very ahead. It both books looks back to a tradition of southern populism. but the way in which he repackages it for the late 20th century is very forward-looking. And he says, look, I'm the champion of the little guy, I'm an ordinary person, I'm not a career politician, I've got my nice plaid shirt, all of this kind of thing. He wins the election, he becomes governor, he's pretty good at it, and by late 1972, he is thinking about running for president.
这是南方民粹主义。它非常超前。它既回顾了南方民粹主义的传统，但它为20世纪末重新包装的方式是非常向前看的。他说，看，我是小人物的捍卫者，我是一个普通人，我不是职业政客，我有我漂亮的格子衬衫，所有这些东西。他赢得了选举，他成为了州长，他做得相当不错，到1972年底，他正在考虑竞选总统。
Now, on the face of it, this is a very long shot. There hasn't been a genuine southern president since Andrew Johnson in the aftermath of the Civil War, And there has never been a president from the deep south, from the really deep south, from the states that had once held millions of slaves from places like Mississippi, Alabama, Georgia and so on. There's never been a president from one of these states. And the other thing that's against Carter, Carter, and this is the thing that now that everyone thinks that Jimmy Carter is a lovely kind guy who built houses for poor people and stuff, people forget. Carter in the 70s was much more conservative than most democratic activists. So, you know, it's a tough gig for him to try to get the presidency, presidential nomination. But unexpectedly, everything falls into his lap.
现在，从表面上看，这是一个非常渺茫的机会。自内战后的安德鲁·约翰逊以来，还没有真正的南方总统，而且从来没有一位来自深南部的总统，来自真正深南部，来自曾经拥有数百万奴隶的州，来自像密西西比、阿拉巴马、乔治亚等地方。从来没有一位来自这些州的总统。而另一件对卡特不利的事情是，卡特，现在每个人都认为吉米·卡特是一个为穷人盖房子的可爱好人，人们忘记了。卡特在70年代比大多数民主党活动家要保守得多。所以，你知道，对他来说，试图获得总统提名是一项艰巨的任务。但出乎意料的是，一切都落到了他的怀里。
So first of all, the Democratic favorite, who is Edward Kennedy, has destroyed himself at Chapquiddick by driving into the, off the bridge, abandoning Mary Joe Capechnie, and then putting on a blazer and walking around on the balcony of his kind of hotel to try and pretend that thing has happened. Meanwhile, in Washington, Watergate has erupted. everybody assumes that all Washington politicians are really corrupt. People are saying, let's have an outsider to drain the swamp, all of this kind of thing. And so Carter comes through in the Democratic primaries.
所以首先，民主党的热门人选，爱德华·肯尼迪，在查帕奎迪克通过开车冲出桥梁，抛弃玛丽·乔·科佩奇尼，然后穿上西装外套在酒店阳台上走来走去试图假装事情没有发生，从而毁了自己。与此同时，在华盛顿，水门事件爆发了。每个人都认为所有的华盛顿政客都很腐败。人们说，让我们找一个局外人来清理沼泽，所有这些东西。所以卡特在民主党初选中脱颖而出。
He plays up the fact that he's an outsider. He's a southerner. He's an evangelical Christian. He's a populist, all of this stuff. He has these ads where he's walking around his farm and his lovely checked shirt. He talks about how he likes to teach Sunday school. And his promise is his policy prescription is so vague. I mean, it's brilliant.
他利用自己是局外人的事实。他是南方人。他是福音派基督徒。他是民粹主义者，所有这些东西。他有这些广告，他在农场里穿着可爱的格子衬衫走来走去。他谈论他喜欢教主日学。他的承诺，他的政策处方是如此模糊。我的意思是，这太棒了。
It's all things to all men. He says, people say, what will it be like when you're president? He says, I will give you, and I'm not going to do the voice because I cannot do a southern accent. He says, do you want to do it, Tom,
这对所有人来说都是万能药。他说，人们说，当你成为总统时会是什么样子？他说，我会给你，我不会模仿那个声音，因为我模仿不了南方口音。他说，你想模仿吗，汤姆，
in your Australian accent? No, you do it. You go for it. He says, I will promise a government that is as good and honest and decent and competent and compassionate and as filled with love as are the American people.
用你的澳大利亚口音？不，你来。你来吧。他说，我承诺一个政府，它将像美国人民一样善良、诚实、正派、称职、富有同情心，并充满爱。
God, as filled with love as are the American people. Yeah. There's a recipe for a happy administration. And instead of reaching for the sick bucket, people say, oh, isn't that nice? That's what we want. So he wins the nomination and then he wins the presidency, he beats Gerald Ford. So now Carter is president and is he good at it? I mean, I think you don't even have to be a critic of Jimmy Carter to say he's actually not really good at it. He doesn't have any contacts on Capitol Hill. He finds it really hard to work with Congress. He's not naturally charming.
天哪，像美国人民一样充满爱。是的。这是一个幸福政府的秘诀。人们没有去拿呕吐桶，而是说，哦，那不是很好吗？这就是我们想要的。所以他赢得了提名，然后他赢得了总统职位，他击败了杰拉尔德·福特。所以现在卡特是总统了，他做得好吗？我的意思是，我认为你甚至不需要成为吉米·卡特的批评者就能说他实际上做得并不好。他在国会山没有任何联系。他发现与国会合作真的很难。他天生不迷人。
I mean, he doesn't exude warmth. Everybody sort of says this in Capitol Hill. He's stubborn. He doesn't like compromising. He works incredibly hard, but it's the classic story. It's a bit Rishi Sunak or something. He works almost too hard. You know, he thinks if he stays up to 3 o'clock in the morning doing his paperwork, he'll be a better president. And actually, that means he just massively overprepairs and overthinks everything. He'll kind of rock up at 9 o'clock in the morning and say, overnight, I've dreamt up a 455 point plan to fight inflation or something. So he begins, doesn't he, he looking very kind of sunny, full of the optimism of the South and all that. And very rapidly he comes to look grey and haggard and worn. Yeah, because he's not sleeping. And in the long run, this isn't going to look good when he goes for a run. No, it will not. It will not look good.
我的意思是，他不散发温暖。每个人在国会山都这么说。他很固执。他不喜欢妥协。他工作极其努力，但这是一个经典的故事。这有点像里希·苏纳克之类的。他工作得太努力了。你知道，他认为如果他熬夜到凌晨3点处理文书工作，他会成为一个更好的总统。而实际上，这意味着他只是过度准备和过度思考一切。他会在早上9点左右出现，说，昨晚，我构思了一个455点的计划来对抗通货膨胀之类的。所以他开始时，不是吗，看起来非常阳光，充满了南方的乐观主义等等。然后很快他就变得灰暗、憔悴和疲惫。是的，因为他没有睡觉。从长远来看，当他去跑步时，这看起来不会很好。不，这看起来不会很好。
And actually, the discussion of the optics are being present. So interesting. So it quite often happens, I think, that people will elect somebody. They'll say, we'd like an ordinary person now. We're sick of all these crap. They don't want that. But they don't really want that. It's like when the French elected Francois Alon,
实际上，关于公众形象的讨论确实存在。这太有趣了。我认为，人们选举某人时经常会发生这种情况。他们会说，我们现在想要一个普通人。我们受够了这些废话。他们不想要那些（政客）。但他们其实并不是真的想要那样。就像法国人选举弗朗索瓦·奥朗德时一样，
What they actually always deep down is want is a statesman. So you mentioned Jimmy Carter's cardigan. He turned up on national television, an early national broadcast wearing a cardigan, and he said, I'd like everybody to turn their thermostat. You can't do that, can you? That's not the imperial presidency. No, not at all. So there's that, there's the cardigan issue.
他们内心深处真正想要的是一位政治家。你提到了吉米·卡特的开襟羊毛衫。他在一次早期的全国电视广播中穿着开襟羊毛衫露面，他说，我希望每个人都调低恒温器。你不能那样做，对吧？那不是帝国总统的作风。不，完全不是。所以，这就是开襟羊毛衫的问题。
There's also the issue. He's a massive micromanager and a meddler. Oh, yes. Famously, the tennis courts thing, which you love, don't you? Yeah, my favorite Jimmy Carter, fact, is that he handles the... the tennis court bookings. Dom Johnson. So Dom Johnson,
还有一个问题。他是个极端的微观管理者和爱管闲事的人。哦，是的。著名的网球场事件，你很喜欢这个，对吧？是的，我最喜欢的关于吉米·卡特的事实是，他亲自处理网球场的预订。多姆·约翰逊。所以多姆·约翰逊，
a blast from the past, our former producer, is in on this call. And he's immediately come, he's jumped into the chat, tennis court bookings. It's one of two things about Jimmy Carter
我们过去的一位制片人，也是这次通话的参与者。他立刻加入了聊天，谈到了网球场预订。这是关于吉米·卡特的两个事实之一，
that we always mention, the tennis court buttings, and another thing that involves a swamp, which will also be, which regular listeners to this podcast will be waiting for
我们总是会提到，网球场预订，还有另一件涉及沼泽的事情，这也是本播客的常客们会屏息以待的。
with bated breath. There are only two facts about Jimmy Carter. Worth knowing. So this is the man at the helm of the world most powerful country. And how is he going to run America's foreign policy?
关于吉米·卡特，只有这两个事实值得了解。所以这就是掌管世界上最强大国家的人。他将如何运行美国的对外政策呢？
Well, he's basically said, no more Vietnam wars. My ethical foreign policy, he says, will reflect the decency and generosity of the American people. So again, people are wiping my tears at this point. We wait, Nick Greenland. I promise. So to be fair to Carter, he has a couple of foreign policy successes, most famously the Camp David Accords between Egypt and Israel, which he sort of mediates in 1978.
嗯，他基本上说，不再有越南战争了。他说，我的道德外交政策将反映美国人民的体面和慷慨。所以，再一次，人们此时正在为我擦眼泪。我们等着瞧，尼克·格陵兰。我保证。公平地说，卡特确实取得了一些外交政策上的成功，最著名的是1978年他在埃及和以色列之间促成的戴维营协议。
but he is hidebound by the fact that Vietnam has happened. There's a general sense the US is going backwards in the Cold War. There is Soviet intervention in Africa and Ethiopia in Zaire and Angola and so on. People are talking about what they call at the time the arc of crisis that runs all the way from southern Africa to Southeast Asia. They say basically Asia is going to, and Africa are going to slip out of the Western orbit. capitalism is in retreat you know Soviet imperialism
但他受限于越南战争已经发生的事实。人们普遍认为美国在冷战中正在走下坡路。苏联在非洲、埃塞俄比亚、扎伊尔和安哥拉等地进行了干预。人们在谈论当时所谓的“危机弧”，它从南部非洲一直延伸到东南亚。他们基本上说，亚洲和非洲将脱离西方轨道。资本主义正在退却，你知道，苏联帝国主义
is emboldened we should stop appeasing them we should get rid of de taunt So can I ask you Dominic Is Carter naturally a dove Or does his say his evangelical Christianity give him a bit of An edge that he can draw
正受到鼓舞，我们应该停止安抚他们，我们应该摆脱缓和政策。那么我可以问你吗，多米尼克，卡特天生就是个鸽派吗？还是说他的福音派基督教信仰给了他某种可以利用的优势？
And when he feels he needs it He is ambiguous So he starts off a little bit more dovish Largely I think Because he's never really thought About foreign policy He's always been You know who's governor of Georgia
当他觉得需要的时候，他是模棱两可的。所以他一开始稍微偏向鸽派，主要是因为我认为他从未真正思考过外交政策。他一直都是，你知道，佐治亚州的州长。
You didn't really have to think about world affairs, a new governor of Georgia. And actually, it was a criticism that people had of him. They said he won't know anything about how to handle world affairs. At first, he strikes a more doveish line, but by about 1978, he's definitely changed his tune, and he is much harder on the Soviet Union. Does his evangelical Christianity play a massive part in that? I don't think it does play a massive part, actually. I just ask, because that sense of the world being divided into good and evil, which of course Reagan will make great play with, but this is also going to be part of the part of the part. perspective that the Ayatollahs bring to their understanding of the world.
作为佐治亚州州长，你真的不需要考虑世界事务。实际上，这也是人们对他的批评。他们说他根本不懂如何处理世界事务。起初，他采取了更温和的路线，但到了1978年左右，他肯定改变了基调，对苏联的态度强硬多了。他的福音派基督教信仰在其中起了很大作用吗？我不认为它起了很大作用。我只是问问，因为那种将世界划分为善与恶的感觉，当然里根会大加利用，但这也将成为阿亚图拉们理解世界视角的一部分。
Yeah. And Carter definitely has a very moralistic sense of the world. And he's comfortable with the language of good and evil in a way that Reagan is and a way that Margaret Thatcher is in Britain in similar period. But there may be older politicians of them. Slightly wince. Yeah, it would slightly wince. They would think of it as a little bit gauche, maybe.
是的。卡特确实有一种非常道德化的世界观。他习惯于使用善与恶的语言，就像里根和同一时期的英国玛格丽特·撒切尔一样。但可能比他们年长的政治家会稍微退缩。是的，会稍微退缩。他们会觉得这有点笨拙，也许吧。
Anyway, this context explains, I think, why Carter goes all in on the shah. So before he became president, I'm guessing that Jimmy Carter had literally never thought about Iran at all. I mean, if you're the governor of Georgia, you never have to worry about Iranian affairs. Here's a US TV fact for you. The US network news in the 1970s typically discussed Iran for five minutes a year. And those five minutes were generally taken up with coverage of the Shah's dinners or him going skiing or his glamorous, you know, his oddly young and glamorous companions. The Shah steps out with glamorous centrefold. Exactly. That's exactly what it was.
总之，我认为这种背景解释了为什么卡特全力支持沙阿。所以在他成为总统之前，我猜吉米·卡特可能从来没想过伊朗。我的意思是，如果你是佐治亚州州长，你永远不必担心伊朗事务。这里有一个关于美国电视的事实给你。20世纪70年代的美国电视新闻网通常每年只讨论伊朗五分钟。而那五分钟通常被用来报道沙阿的晚宴，或者他去滑雪，或者他那些迷人的、你知道的，他那些年轻而迷人的同伴。沙阿带着迷人的封面女郎出场。没错。事实正是如此。
Now, Carter was aware that the Shah was getting a bit of a kicking from liberals about his human rights record. And he put a little bit of pressure on the Shah to ameliorate this. And actually in 1977, the Shah said, fair enough, we're going to stop torturing people. And I'll let the Red Cross in to have a look at my prisons. And we shall allow poets and writers. Here are your poets again for you, Tom. which will allow them to have meetings and talk about liberal ideas
现在，卡特意识到沙阿因为他的人权记录而受到自由派的抨击。他给沙阿施加了一点压力，要求改善这种情况。实际上在1977年，沙阿说，好吧，我们将停止折磨人。我会让红十字会进去看看我的监狱。我们将允许诗人和作家。汤姆，你的诗人们又来了。我们将允许他们举行会议，谈论自由思想
and political reforms and so on and so forth. However, Carter doesn't want to go too far on this. So in June 177, he appoints a new ambassador to Iran called William Sullivan, who's going to be a big character in this series. William Sullivan is a career diplomat. He's got this white kind of buffon hair. He's regarded as a loose cannon. We love a loose cannon in American diplomatic debacle.
和政治改革等等。然而，卡特不想在这方面走得太远。所以1977年6月，他任命了一位新的驻伊朗大使，名叫威廉·沙利文，他将成为这个系列中的重要人物。威廉·沙利文是一位职业外交官。他留着那种白色的蓬松头发。他被视为一个“脱缰的野马”。我们喜欢美国外交灾难中的“脱缰野马”。
We definitely do. So he's very outspanourable. spoken, he's very asserbic, he doesn't suffer fools gladly. They point him to the embassy in Tehran. And Carter says to him, look, I want you to treat the Shah as our close friend. He's a really important ally for us. Iran is, and I quote, our guarantee of stability and security in the Persian Gulf, all of this. And Sullivan says, aren't you the human rights guy? Like, is human rights that important to you? And Carter actually says to him, don't, don't overthink this. Like, don't worry too much about the human rights thing. Iran is so important.
我们确实喜欢。所以他非常直言不讳，非常尖刻，他不能容忍愚蠢。他们指派他去德黑兰大使馆。卡特对他说，听着，我希望你把沙阿当作我们的亲密朋友。他确实是我们非常重要的盟友。伊朗是，我引用一下，“我们波斯湾稳定与安全的保障”，所有这些。沙利文说，你不是那个搞人权的家伙吗？人权对你来说真的那么重要吗？卡特实际上对他说，别，别想太多。别太担心人权问题。伊朗太重要了。
to us, not least because we have listening posts on the Soviet border with Iran that are massively important to us. So, you know, don't get too carried away with this human rights business. Yeah, we'd like the Shah to stop attacking people with cattle prods, but, you know, having him on side is so important. So the Shah comes to Washington in November 1977. Carter rolls out the red carpet for him. And afterwards, Carter says publicly, the Shah is brilliant. I love the show. He's more impressive than any other leader, certainly any European leader I've ever met. And what's so hurtful about this, Tom,
对我们来说，尤其是因为我们在伊朗与苏联的边界上有监听站，这对我们来说非常重要。所以，你知道，别太沉迷于人权这档子事。是的，我们希望沙阿停止用电棍攻击人，但是，你知道，让他站在我们这边太重要了。所以沙阿在1977年11月来到华盛顿。卡特为他铺上了红地毯。事后，卡特公开表示，沙阿太棒了。我爱沙阿。他比我见过的任何其他领导人，当然包括任何欧洲领导人，都更令人印象深刻。汤姆，最伤人的是，
is the show at this point has met James Callahan. So what is he thinking? Terrible judge of character. What can we tell? Terrible judge of character. So this is what sets the scene for this trip that Carter then makes in return to Tehran on New Year's Eve, 1977.
沙阿此时已经见过詹姆斯·卡拉汉了。那么他在想什么呢？糟糕的识人能力。我们能说什么呢？糟糕的识人能力。所以这就是卡特随后在1977年除夕回访德黑兰的背景。
And again, it's a very gilded scene. So one American reporter said it felt like Versailles in the days of Louis XIV. There's caviar, there's Don Perignon, there's Rose Partridge, there's this gigantic ice cream flambay. And Carter gives this speech and he says, I ask my wife Rosalind where she'd like to spend New Year's Eve because we were going to be abroad. And she said, the people I love most are the Shah and Empress Farah. And everybody says, oh, isn't that lovely? And Carter says, I mean, it's unbelievable when you read the speech.
同样，这是一个非常奢华的场景。一位美国记者说，感觉就像路易十四时代的凡尔赛宫。有鱼子酱，有唐·培里侬香槟，有烤鹧鸪，还有巨大的冰淇淋火焰蛋糕。卡特发表了演讲，他说，我问我的妻子罗莎琳，因为我们要出国，她想在哪里度过除夕。她说，我最爱的人是沙阿和法拉赫皇后。每个人都说，哦，那不是很可爱吗？卡特说，我的意思是，当你读到这段演讲时，真是令人难以置信。
He says, I really love human rights. And what's nice for me is I know the Shah. I know you love human rights too. How profoundly impressed I've been, he says, with your wisdom, your judgment, your sensitivity and insight. How moved I was when we drove through Tehran. And I saw literally thousands of Iranian citizens standing beside the street with a friendly attitude expressing their welcome to me.
他说，我真的很热爱人权。对我来说好的是，我了解沙阿。我知道你也热爱人权。他说，你的智慧、你的判断力、你的敏感和洞察力给我留下了多么深刻的印象。当我开车穿过德黑兰时，我是多么感动。我看到成千上万的伊朗公民站在街边，以友好的态度表达对我的欢迎。
And beside them, thousands of American citizens, there are now 50,000 Americans in Iran, who stood there welcoming their president in a nation which has taken them to heart and made them feel at home. Well, it never occurs to Carter. Carter, who is so inexperienced in world affairs, it never occurs to him when he's saying these words that he has gambled his entire presidency
在他们旁边，成千上万的美国公民，现在有5万名美国人在伊朗，他们站在那里欢迎他们的总统，在一个已经接纳了他们并让他们感到宾至如归的国家。好吧，卡特从未想到。卡特，在世界事务上如此缺乏经验，当他说这些话时，他从未想到他已经把整个总统任期
on a doomed regime. But Tom, just eight days later in the city of Gom, the first fires are lit in a revolution that will change things forever. And at the center of this conflagration is a man who has a very different, vision for Iran and its people, and that is the Ayatollah, Rouhola, Khomeini. Thrilling stuff. We will be back after the break to hear from the Ayatollah.
押注在一个注定要失败的政权上。但汤姆，仅仅八天后，在库姆市，一场将永远改变一切的革命点燃了第一把火。在这场大火的中心，有一个人对伊朗及其人民有着非常不同的愿景，那就是阿亚图拉·鲁霍拉·霍梅尼。激动人心的内容。休息后我们将回来听听阿亚图拉的声音。
All our miseries are caused by the imperialists. If they were not protected by the Iranian government, the people would skin them alive. Everything in our treasury is emptied into the pockets of America. And if there is anything left, it goes to the Shah and his gang. They buy themselves foreign villas and stuff their bank accounts with the people's money while the nation starves. So brave sons of Islam stand up. Talk to the people. Tell the truth to the masses. Rouse the people in the streets and the bazaars. Rouse our students. Rouse our simple-hearted workers and peasants.
我们所有的苦难都是由帝国主义者造成的。如果不是受到伊朗政府的保护，人民早就把他们活剥了。我们国库里的一切都被掏空进了美国的口袋。如果还有剩下的，就进了沙阿和他那帮人的腰包。他们给自己买外国别墅，把人民的钱塞进银行账户，而国家却在挨饿。所以，伊斯兰勇敢的儿子们，站起来。去和人民交谈。告诉群众真相。在街道和集市上唤醒人民。唤醒我们的学生。唤醒我们心地善良的工人和农民。
And let us become holy warriors. So welcome back to the rest of the rest of the world. West is history and what you heard there were the dulcet tones of the Ayatollah Rahmani. And he was speaking from exile in Iraq, in the city of Najaf in February 1978. And Dominic, the Ayatollah is one of the iconic figures of 20th century revolution. Isn't he? He's up there with Lenin, with Mao. Everyone recognizes him.
让我们成为圣战者。欢迎回到《西方即历史》，你们刚才听到的是阿亚图拉·霍梅尼甜美的声音。他当时是在1978年2月从伊拉克的纳杰夫市流亡期间发表讲话的。多米尼克，阿亚图拉是20世纪革命的标志性人物之一，不是吗？他和列宁、毛泽东并列。每个人都认得他。
His long beard, his bristling eyebrows, his general expression of fun. Yes, exactly. And Americans in particular will think of him as one of history's great villains. But as always with people who are regarded, you know, as great villains or indeed great heroes, it's always interesting to dig into the kind of the reality behind the iconic image. He was born in the market town of Khomein in central Iran, probably in 1900. And he came from a reasonably well-off family. His father and grandfather have both been clerics.
他那长长的胡须，那竖起的眉毛，他那标志性的严肃表情。是的，完全正确。美国人尤其会认为他是历史上最伟大的恶棍之一。但正如对待那些被视为伟大恶棍或伟大英雄的人一样，深入挖掘标志性形象背后的现实总是很有趣的。他出生在伊朗中部的库姆镇，大概是在1900年。他来自一个相当富裕的家庭。他的父亲和祖父都是神职人员。
his father was killed in a fight when he was a toddler and he was raised by his uncle and aunt he was by all accounts a very clever boy he began supposedly began reading the koran when he was six he was very good at football apparently he played football he loved poetry and actually he loves poetry all his life but he was clearly very serious and reserved he probably got on well with jimmy carter actually well that's the irony isn't it i mean that there are kind of echoes between America and Iran throughout this entire conflict. I mean, just to say about communi's upbringing, that the background to it, you said that his father was killed in a brawl.
他父亲在他蹒跚学步时在一次争斗中被杀，他由叔叔和姑姑抚养长大。据所有人的说法，他是一个非常聪明的男孩。据说他六岁就开始读《古兰经》。他显然很擅长足球，他踢足球，他热爱诗歌，实际上他一生都热爱诗歌。但他显然非常严肃和内敛。他可能和吉米·卡特相处得很好。嗯，这就是讽刺之处，不是吗？我的意思是，在整个冲突中，美国和伊朗之间存在某种回响。我的意思是，关于霍梅尼的成长经历，你说他父亲是在一场斗殴中被杀的。
I mean, this is the period of the that build up to the First World War and the First World War itself, and it is very violent. Yes. And I think that when he ends up going to a seminary, and I think that that provides him with a kind of refuge from the chaos of life outside and must be a hugely formative. in his association of Islam with peace. Completely, completely.
我的意思是，这是第一次世界大战前夕和第一次世界大战本身的时期，非常暴力。是的。我认为，当他最终进入神学院时，这为他提供了一种逃避外部世界混乱的避难所，这一定对他产生了巨大的影响，使他将伊斯兰教与和平联系在一起。完全是这样，完全是这样。
So as you say he goes to the seminary in this place called Com, which is a holy city because it has the shrine of somebody called Fatima Bint Musa, who is the sister of the eighth Shia Imam. And we don't need to massively get into that right now.
所以正如你所说，他去了库姆这个地方的神学院，这是一个圣城，因为它有法蒂玛·宾特·穆萨的陵墓，她是第八位什叶派伊玛目的妹妹。我们现在不需要深入探讨这个问题。
Anyway, it's a holy city. He's at the seminary. He finds security in Khan, as you say. He does law there. He does philosophy, doesn't he? Greek philosophy. He does. But philosophy is his
总之，这是一个圣城。他在神学院。正如你所说，他在库姆找到了安全感。他在那里学习法律。他学习哲学，不是吗？希腊哲学。是的。但哲学是他的
real focus and it's a particular focus on Greek philosophy. So Aristotle and particularly Plato and how they have been mediated by the kind of traditions of Islamic and specifically Shia thinking. Exactly. So Khomeini is, he's a serious and very clever person. He writes poetry, studies poetry. He's very interested in mysticism. He becomes one of the most respected scholars at the seminary. I mean, you know who he actually also reminds me of is Pope John Paul II. Also a footballer, a poet, becomes
真正焦点，特别是对希腊哲学的关注。所以亚里士多德，特别是柏拉图，以及他们是如何被伊斯兰教，特别是什叶派思想的传统所调和的。没错。所以霍梅尼是一个严肃且非常聪明的人。他写诗，研究诗歌。他对神秘主义非常感兴趣。他成为了神学院最受尊敬的学者之一。我的意思是，你知道他实际上还让我想起了教皇约翰·保罗二世。也是足球运动员，诗人，成为了
a titanic religious leader of the 70s and 80s. Certain parallel there. Yeah. So by the time he's about 50, people are calling him Ayatollah, which is a term of respect for an especially learned scholar. And everybody acknowledges he's an incredibly charismatic and impressive
70年代和80年代泰坦级的宗教领袖。确实有某种平行之处。是的。所以到他50岁左右时，人们开始称他为“阿亚图拉”，这是对特别博学的学者的尊称。每个人都承认他是一个非常有魅力和令人印象深刻的
person. He always wears this black robe, this black turban. He's got his beard, his perfectly groomed. He has this hypnotic, unwavering stare. He always looks implacable and formidable. He never is seen smiling or laughing in public. And this is because he's very conscious of his seriousness and his dignity. And there's a sort of austerity to him, which is reflected in his private life. So he married his wife when she was in her early teens. He's not a big, you know, Unlike the Shah, he doesn't have dishes flown in from maxims of Paris.
人。他总是穿着那件黑色的长袍，戴着那顶黑色的头巾。他的胡须修剪得非常完美。他有一种催眠般的、坚定不移的凝视。他看起来总是不可动摇且令人生畏。在公共场合从未见过他微笑或大笑。这是因为他非常在意自己的严肃性和尊严。他有一种苦行僧般的特质，这反映在他的私生活中。所以他在妻子十几岁时就娶了她。他不是一个，你知道，不像沙阿，他没有从巴黎马克西姆餐厅空运来的菜肴。
He doesn't own much. He spends his time. You know, to relax, he prays, he meditates, he goes for a walk. So maybe we should talk a little bit. I know you want to talk a bit of you, Tom, about the importance of Shia Islam to our story. It's so fundamental. Just to give people a sense of what we mean, in the early days of the Islamic conquests, after the death of Muhammad, there was basically a disagreement about who would succeed, wasn't that?
他拥有的东西不多。他花时间。你知道，为了放松，他祈祷，他冥想，他去散步。所以也许我们应该谈谈。汤姆，我知道你想谈谈什叶派伊斯兰教对我们故事的重要性。这太基础了。为了让人们了解我们的意思，在伊斯兰征服的早期，在穆罕默德去世后，关于谁来继位基本上存在分歧，不是吗？
And Shiites believe that the Islamic community took a wrong path. The leadership should have remained in the family of Mohammed's son-in-law, Ali. Well, specifically, Dominic, the family of the prophet himself, because Ali is married to the daughter of Muhammad. And so their sons, Hassan and Hussein, are the grandchildren of the prophet, but they don't succeed. They end up being killed. And we'll come to that in a minute.
什叶派认为伊斯兰社区走错了路。领导权应该留在穆罕默德的女婿阿里家族手中。嗯，具体来说，多米尼克，是先知本人的家族，因为阿里娶了穆罕默德的女儿。所以他们的儿子哈桑和侯赛因是先知的孙子，但他们没有继位。他们最终被杀了。我们一会儿会谈到这一点。
And over time, their faction basically evolves into its own sect with its own history and its own traditions and its own rituals. Yeah, so they are the Shiat Ali, the party of Allah, so that's where Shia comes from. Shia or Shiites. So they are now in the world today, about 10 to 15% of Muslims. The vast majority of Muslims are sunny, but the Shia or the Shiites are this minority. And Iran had been a Shia or Shiite since about the 1500s when the Safafid people, dynasty imposed it as the state religion. And it became an really, really important part of Iranian identity because it distinguished them from the neighboring Arabic-speaking countries,
随着时间的推移，他们的派系基本上演变成了一个拥有自己历史、传统和仪式的教派。是的，所以他们是“阿里党”，即真主的党，这就是“什叶”的由来。什叶派。所以他们现在在当今世界上，大约占穆斯林的10%到15%。绝大多数穆斯林是逊尼派，但什叶派是少数。自1500年左右萨法维王朝将其定为国教以来，伊朗一直是什叶派国家。这成为了伊朗身份中非常、非常重要的一部分，因为它使他们区别于邻近的讲阿拉伯语的国家，
which were sunny Muslim. So it made Iran feel different. And it had two massive consequences for our story. So one of them is that, I mean, I know you're going to say a little bit more about this, that at the heart of the Shia belief system is this idea that you have, You know, it's a belief system based on the idea of oppression and authority and virtuous, austere, martyrs and victims who are being oppressed by overweening state authority or overweening authority of one kind or another. And the primal victims and martyrs in this belief system are Ali, the son-in-law of the prophet, who had a caliph, who had been assassinated.
那些国家是逊尼派穆斯林。所以这让伊朗感觉与众不同。这对我们的故事有两个巨大的影响。所以其中之一是，我的意思是，我知道你会多说一点，什叶派信仰体系的核心是这种观念，你知道，这是一个基于压迫、权威、美德、苦行、殉道者和受害者的信仰体系，他们受到过度膨胀的国家权力或某种过度权力的压迫。在这个信仰体系中，原始的受害者和殉道者是先知的女婿阿里，他是一位哈里发，被暗杀了。
but more particularly Ali's son, the grandson of the prophet, we've already mentioned him, Hussein, who was killed in a battle in Iraq, a place called Karbala in 680 by the Amad's who the dynasty, who then establish a kind of imperial rule. And this for the Shia is where everything goes wrong, not just in the context of kind of late antique politics, but on a cosmic scale because this for them is about the triumph of evil over good, and it's about the derailing of Muhammad's prophetic mission, which is a mission for the whole of humanity, the embodiment of God's plan for the world. And so, Hussein's death in this battle at Kabul is seen as the primal catastrophe.
但更具体地说是阿里的儿子，先知的孙子，我们已经提到过他，侯赛因，他在680年伊拉克的一个叫卡尔巴拉的地方被倭马亚王朝杀害，该王朝随后建立了一种帝国统治。对于什叶派来说，这就是一切出错的地方，不仅是在古典晚期政治的背景下，而且是在宇宙尺度上，因为对他们来说，这是邪恶战胜善良，这是对穆罕默德先知使命的破坏，这是一个为了全人类的使命，是上帝对世界计划的体现。因此，侯赛因在卡尔巴拉战役中的死亡被视为原始的灾难。
And it is commemorated as a kind of great act of self-sacrifice on the part of Hussein. He's laying down his life for the good of all the world. It will strike people that there are slight echoes there of Good Friday of the death of Christ. I mean, I think that's not coincidental. There are a lot of Christians in this period in Iran and in Iraq, and I think it is channeling those kind of Christian understandings of sacrifice on the part of humanity. And so the day of Hussein's death, Ashura, which is the 10th day of the first month of the Muslim calendar, Muharram, is the great day of mourning for the Shia, and it is essentially their
它被纪念为侯赛因的一种伟大的自我牺牲行为。他为全人类的利益献出了生命。人们会觉得这与耶稣受难日的基督之死有轻微的回响。我的意思是，我认为这并非巧合。在这一时期的伊朗和伊拉克有很多基督徒，我认为它正在引导那种人类牺牲的基督教理解。因此，侯赛因去世的日子，阿舒拉节，即穆斯林历第一个月的第10天，穆哈拉姆月，是什叶派伟大的哀悼日，它本质上是他们的
kind of Good Friday. Yeah. And this in turn feeds into a strongly apocalyptic perspective on the world because if things have gone wrong, then at some point God will intervene to ensure that they will go right. And the person who will emerge is this figure called the Mardi, who is the 12th of the imams. And the imams are people with a kind of cosmic mission to write and order the world. And the first of these imams have been Ali, Hussein had been the third, the 12th. himam, the hidden imam, the Mardi, he will appear and according to Shiite tradition, he will avenge the blood of Hussein that was spilled at Kabulah, and this will, to quote Abbas Amanat in his brilliant book, Apocalyptic Islam and Iranian Shiasm, it will initiate an apocalyptic battle of cosmic
某种耶稣受难日。是的。这反过来又助长了一种强烈的世界末日视角，因为如果事情出了差错，那么在某个时候上帝会干预以确保它们走上正轨。而将要出现的人就是这个被称为“马赫迪”的人物，他是第12位伊玛目。伊玛目是具有某种宇宙使命来纠正和治理世界的人。第一位伊玛目是阿里，侯赛因是第三位，第12位伊玛目，隐遁的伊玛目，马赫迪，他将会出现，根据什叶派传统，他将为在卡尔巴拉流下的侯赛因的血复仇，这将，引用阿巴斯·阿马纳特在他精彩的著作《末日伊斯兰与伊朗什叶派》中的话，它将引发一场宇宙规模的末日之战，
proportion that precedes the day as a resurrection and the end of time. And people may feel that all this discussion of late antique theology in the context of 1970s politics might seem a bit rescherche, but it absolutely isn't because it is impossible, I think, to understand the Iranian revolution without an awareness of how important this apocalyptic understanding of the world is to the Ayatollah and to his followers. And it's precise because the American foreign policy establishment have no comprehension of this at all. that they don't really know how to handle the Ayatollah when he emerges onto the scene. Exactly.
这预示着复活日和时间的终结。人们可能会觉得所有这些关于古典晚期神学的讨论在1970年代政治的背景下可能显得有点深奥，但绝对不是，因为我认为，如果不了解这种末日世界观对阿亚图拉及其追随者的重要性，就不可能理解伊朗革命。正是因为美国外交政策机构对此完全没有理解，他们才不知道在阿亚图拉出现时该如何处理他。没错。
So for people to keep in their heads, the Ayatollah has this sense of victimhood and suffering. They have this particular day that's massively important that's grounded in history, Ashura, and they have this apocalyptic sense of the end of days and all of this kind of thing. So that's one thing. And then the other thing to bear in mind about Shia Islam is that local clergy are really, really important in this world. So Bakr Mouin, who is Khomeini's biographer, has really, really good sections about this. So the mullahs, the clerics or priests, I guess, in Shia Islam always had tremendous local clout. So in these small towns and villages, in what was then called Persia and later Iran,
所以人们要记住，阿亚图拉有这种受害者和苦难的感觉。他们有这个在历史上根深蒂固的极其重要的日子，阿舒拉节，他们有这种关于末日的末世感等等。所以这是一件事。关于什叶派伊斯兰教，另一件要记住的事情是，当地神职人员在这个世界中非常、非常重要。所以巴克尔·穆因，他是霍梅尼的传记作者，对此有非常、非常好的章节。所以毛拉，即神职人员或牧师，我想在什叶派伊斯兰教中，一直拥有巨大的地方影响力。所以在这些小城镇和村庄里，在当时被称为波斯后来被称为伊朗的地方，
the cleric was the judge, he was the teacher, he was a kind of storyteller, he was a massively, massively important figure. He could read and write and most people couldn't. The cleric handled all your legal transactions. The cleric acted as a kind of arbiter and a mediator. Often in small local places, he was the main authority figure. And people looked to him, not to the state, and they saw the clerics often as a kind of counterweight the state, not part of it. Yes, and actually also crucial for people to bear in mind is that clerics
神职人员是法官，是老师，是某种讲故事的人，是一个非常、非常重要的人物。他能读写，而大多数人不能。神职人员处理你所有的法律交易。神职人员充当某种仲裁者和调解人。通常在小地方，他是主要的权威人物。人们仰望他，而不是国家，他们通常将神职人员视为某种制衡国家的力量，而不是国家的一部分。是的，实际上对人们来说至关重要的是要记住，神职人员
pointedly did not aspire to control the state. They did not aspire to the leadership, say, of Iran. And this again is rooted in the kind of distinctive character of Shiite theology, because Shiites see legitimate governance, what guardianship, Vela'at, it's called in Persian, as having perished with Ali and Hussein. And therefore, basically throughout history, Shiites have rejected the very notion of a kind of legitimate state. They don't think it exists. And this will only change with the coming of the Mardi. And again, to quote Aminat, the belief that all temporal powers are considered unjust was carried almost to the point of anarchistic idealism. So this for Shiite clerics opposed to the Shah, it inspires them in their opposition to his rule, but it also leaves them with a problem, which is that who is going to step into the gap? Because there's nothing in the Shiite tradition that would say that clerks. would take that step. Right. So one last point about these clerics, they often are quite well off because there are authority
明确表示不渴望控制国家。他们不渴望领导伊朗。这再次植根于什叶派神学独特的特征，因为什叶派认为合法的治理，波斯语称为“维拉亚特”（Vela'at），随着阿里和侯赛因的去世而消亡了。因此，基本上在整个历史上，什叶派都拒绝了某种合法国家的概念。他们认为它不存在。这只有在马赫迪到来时才会改变。再次引用阿马纳特的观点，所有世俗权力都被视为不公正的信念，几乎被推向了无政府主义理想主义的地步。所以对于反对沙阿的什叶派神职人员来说，这激发了他们对沙阿统治的反对，但也给他们留下了一个问题，那就是谁来填补这个空白？因为什叶派传统中没有任何东西会说神职人员会采取那一步。对。所以关于这些神职人员的最后一点，他们通常相当富裕，因为他们是当地社区的权威
figures in their local communities and whatnot. And in the towns and the cities, they become very closely connected to the merchant and artisan classes who basically run the bazaars, the marketplaces. And this actually is the social nexus that powers the Iranian revolution, the alliance of these shopkeepers and artisans in the cities with the clerical elite. Now the cleric's political independence is massively, massively important to them. It's a huge part of their political identity, but all through the Ayatollah Khomeini's life, there has been tension with the state in Tehran.
人物等等。在城镇和城市里，他们与基本上经营集市、市场的商人和工匠阶层联系非常紧密。这实际上是推动伊朗革命的社会纽带，即这些城市店主和工匠与神职精英的联盟。现在，神职人员的政治独立性对他们来说非常、非常重要。这是他们政治身份的巨大组成部分，但在阿亚图拉·霍梅尼的一生中，与德黑兰的国家一直存在紧张关系。
I mentioned in the first half that his father in the 1930s had been a moderniser. He was very much cut from the same cloth as Ataturk in Turkey. So a little bit Peter the Great, actually, for people who remember that series that we did. So Rezaa Pahlavi had wanted to electrify. literally electrify Iran, to bring in ID cards, to have railways, to have people wear Western clothes. He tried to clamp down on people wearing veils and turbans. He even got his military officers to try to shave off clerics' beards. Very Peter the Great.
我在前半部分提到，他的父亲在20世纪30年代是一位现代化者。他非常像土耳其的阿塔图尔克。所以实际上有点像彼得大帝，对于记得我们那个系列的人来说。所以礼萨·巴列维想要电气化。字面意义上的电气化伊朗，引入身份证，修建铁路，让人们穿西式服装。他试图取缔人们戴面纱和头巾。他甚至让他的军官试图剃掉神职人员的胡须。非常像彼得大帝。
The clerics absolutely hated it. And they said this is a classic example of why the Pahlavi dynasty are Western parvenues and puppets. And they're just totally legitimate. And just to be clear, this is obviously on one level ideological, but it is also seen as an attack on their economic standing. Yes, it is exactly even more so in the 1960s. So in the 1960s, Reza's son is now Shah, and the Shah launches a thing that she calls the White Revolution, which is this big modernisation drive. And he thinks, he thinks this will make him very popular. He says, let's have public works. Let's have land reform. Let's encourage people to have a literacy drive. so people can read and write. Let's give women the vote.
神职人员绝对讨厌它。他们说这是巴列维王朝是西方暴发户和傀儡的典型例子。他们完全不合法。需要明确的是，这在某种程度上显然是意识形态上的，但也被视为对他们经济地位的攻击。是的，在20世纪60年代更是如此。所以20世纪60年代，礼萨的儿子现在是沙阿，沙阿发起了一项他称之为“白色革命”的运动，这是一场大规模的现代化运动。他认为，他认为这会让他非常受欢迎。他说，让我们进行公共工程。让我们进行土地改革。让我们鼓励人们进行扫盲运动，
Let's give women more rights. The chance to wear miniskirts. Right. Let's expand state education. Why shouldn't you be taught by trained teachers rather than the local cleric? Now, the local clerics do not like this at all. For all kinds of reasons.
这样人们就能读写了。让我们给女性投票权。让我们给女性更多权利。穿迷你裙的机会。对。让我们扩大国家教育。为什么不应该由训练有素的老师而不是当地神职人员来教你呢？现在，当地神职人员一点也不喜欢这样。出于各种原因。
Many of them come from land-owning families. So their estates are the ones that will be broken up and distributed to the poor. The legal reforms, their role, I mentioned before, that they play the part of the lawyer or the judge or the notary, they're going to lose some of that authority. They will also lose control of education if the Shah brings in all these educational reforms.
他们中的许多人来自土地所有者家庭。所以他们的地产将被分割并分配给穷人。法律改革，他们的角色，我之前提到过，他们扮演律师、法官或公证人的角色，他们将失去部分权威。如果沙阿推行所有这些教育改革，他们也将失去对教育的控制。
And they're like, well, this is, it's not just ripping up our traditions, this is a massive threat to our way of life and our local standing. And it's at this point in the 1960s that Khomeini decides to enter politics. So he steps forward as the guy who's standing up against all this. And he says, he gives a series of sermons in which he says, the Shah is a tyrant.
他们会说，好吧，这不仅仅是撕毁我们的传统，这对我们的生活方式和地方地位是一个巨大的威胁。正是在20世纪60年代，霍梅尼决定进入政坛。所以他站出来作为反对这一切的人。他说，他发表了一系列布道，在布道中他说，沙阿是一个暴君。
He is a traitor. He is the puppet of the United States and of Israel, which has already become the great enemy in the sort of demonology of the clerics. He says, you know, his father was kicked out and the Shah, this miserable wretched man, he'll be kicked out as well if he doesn't change his ways. The Shah has him arrested. He spends time under house arrest. then he's allowed out and then in 1964 he goes back on the offensive and this time very interestingly
他是一个叛徒。他是美国和以色列的傀儡，以色列在神职人员的恶魔学中已经成为了大敌人。他说，你知道，他父亲被赶走了，沙阿这个可怜的、卑微的人，如果他不改变他的方式，他也会被赶走。沙阿逮捕了他。他在软禁中度过了一段时间，然后他被释放，然后在1964年他再次发起进攻，这一次非常有趣，
and I think this is an important clue to Khomeini's appeal what Khomeini speaks out about is a deal that will give legal immunity to American military personnel if they get into trouble in Iran it's a pretty standard agreement that the Americans have in places where they're American bases that if our GIs behave badly they won't be tried by your courts they'll be tried by our military courts And Khomeini says, this is an absolute disgrace. He says, the Shah has reduced us to a level of a colony and made the Muslim nation of Iran appear more backward than savages in the eyes of the world. He says this is all a Zionist plot.
我认为这是霍梅尼吸引力的一个重要线索，霍梅尼谈论的是一项协议，如果美国军事人员在伊朗惹上麻烦，他们将获得法律豁免权。这是一个相当标准的协议，美国人在有美国基地的国家都有这种协议，如果我们的士兵表现不好，他们不会被你们的法院审判，他们会被我们的军事法庭审判。霍梅尼说，这绝对是耻辱。他说，沙阿把我们降到了殖民地的水平，使伊朗这个穆斯林国家在世界眼中显得比野蛮人还要落后。他说这一切都是犹太复国主义的阴谋。
President Lyndon Johnson, and I quote, the most repulsive member of the human race is a Zionist agent. And I don't doubt that Khomey genuinely thought this, but there's also an element of calculation here. He tells his friends, he's quoted as having told his friends, we must use this issue as a weapon so that the people will realize that the Shah is an American agent. And I think this is a really important part of his sort of political repertoire, that he blends what you might see as religious conservatism or traditionalism
林登·约翰逊总统，我引用一下，“人类中最令人厌恶的成员”是一个犹太复国主义代理人。我不怀疑霍梅尼确实是这样想的，但这里也有计算的成分。他告诉他的朋友们，据引用他告诉他的朋友们，我们必须把这个问题当作武器，这样人们就会意识到沙阿是美国的代理人。我认为这是他政治剧目中非常重要的一部分，他将你可能视为宗教保守主义或传统主义的东西
with a kind of anti-colonial nationalism that is so fashionable and popular in the 1950s and the 1960s across Asia, not just in Iran. And so this is why in due course he can be celebrated by people. people in the West on the left as a figure to be admired. As an anti-imperialist champion and all of this. Anyway, this was too much for the Shah. The Shah had him arrested again and they kicked him out to the country. And he ends up in another holy city, Najaf, in Iraq, where the great hero of Shiite religion, Ali, is buried.
与一种在20世纪50年代和60年代在亚洲，不仅仅是在伊朗，非常流行和受欢迎的反殖民民族主义融合在一起。所以这就是为什么在适当的时候，他可以被西方左翼人士赞美为值得钦佩的人物。作为反帝国主义的捍卫者等等。总之，这对沙阿来说太过分了。沙阿再次逮捕了他，并将他驱逐出境。他最终来到了伊拉克的另一个圣城纳杰夫，什叶派宗教的伟大英雄阿里就埋葬在那里。
And there, Khomeini and his wife live in this little house with all their followers and their Acolytes. And he becomes this sort of symbol of resistance to the Shah. So he will sit there, you know, day after day, praying and reading and teaching and whatnot. And his supporters make tape recordings of his lectures and his sermons and they smuggle them into Iran. Now maybe there's an alternative universe where he would just have stayed in the Japh and he kind of mouldered away giving his speeches and no one would have cared. And some listeners may say, well, Iran was getting very rich in the 60s and 70s with oil money. It's becoming more urban.
在那里，霍梅尼和他的妻子与他们所有的追随者和侍从住在这个小房子里。他成为了这种对沙阿抵抗的象征。所以他会坐在那里，你知道，日复一日，祈祷、阅读、教书等等。他的支持者录下了他的讲座和布道，并把它们偷运到伊朗。现在也许有一个平行宇宙，他会一直待在纳杰夫，他会因为发表演讲而发霉，没有人会在意。一些听众可能会说，嗯，伊朗在60年代和70年代靠石油钱变得非常富有。它变得更加城市化。
It's got its nice reforms. It's becoming more literate. Who cares about some bloat with a beard over the border in Iraq? But the truth is that all of the changes that Iran is undergoing, they actually play into Khomeini's hands. You might say, you know, the Shah's actually been good for Iran. He's spent all this money on new railways and stuff. Healthcare has expanded massively education.
它有很好的改革。它变得更有文化。谁会在意边境那边伊拉克的一个留着胡子的胖子呢？但事实是，伊朗正在经历的所有变化，实际上都落入了霍梅尼的手中。你可能会说，你知道，沙阿实际上对伊朗很好。他把所有的钱都花在了新铁路等项目上。医疗保健得到了极大的扩展，教育。
He's invested in Iran's industry. And actually, if you're a woman, or if you're a member of an ethnic minority. I mean, Iran has a lot of minorities, kind of Kurds. And religious minorities as well. Yeah, religious minorities. They are better off under the Shah than they had ever been before in Iranian history. I mean, just on women, there are Islamic dress codes which the Shah is contemptuous of.
他投资了伊朗的工业。实际上，如果你是一名女性，或者如果你是少数民族的一员。我的意思是，伊朗有很多少数民族，比如库尔德人。还有宗教少数群体。是的，宗教少数群体。他们在沙阿统治下比伊朗历史上任何时候都过得好。我的意思是，就女性而言，沙阿对伊斯兰着装规范是蔑视的。
Yes. And so if you are not devoutly Muslim in the traditional sense, as a woman, you can wear what you like. but obviously if that becomes a very obvious visual symbol of what is at stake, both for secularists and for traditional Muslims. Well, people would say in the 60s and 70s they would come to Tehran from the countryside and they would see huge Western billboards for, you know, showing what they regarded as half-naked women, you know, advertising, hoardings and so on. And they were shocked by it. They were really shocked. But they would see women in miniskirts drinking in bars with men. Of course, exactly. And they would see foreign women, by the way, you know, American women and so on,
是的。所以如果你不是传统意义上虔诚的穆斯林，作为女性，你可以穿任何你想穿的衣服。但显然，如果这成为世俗主义者和传统穆斯林双方利害攸关的非常明显的视觉符号。好吧，人们在60年代和70年代会从农村来到德黑兰，他们会看到巨大的西方广告牌，你知道，展示他们认为半裸的女性，你知道，广告牌等等。他们对此感到震惊。他们真的感到震惊。但他们会看到穿着迷你裙的女性在酒吧里和男人喝酒。当然，没错。而且他们会看到外国女性，顺便说一句，你知道，美国女性等等，
because they're not 50,000 Americans, but we'll come to this. The enormous oil boom of the 60s and 70s has proved a very mixed blessing for Iran. It's created a deep sense of inequality. There's a conspicuous gap between rural peasants and the urban poor on one hand, and then the winners, the metropolitan elite on the other. Crucially, it's triggered massive inflation. So prices in the 70s are rising about 15% a year. It's very kind of Spain after the conquest of the Americas,
因为他们不是5万名美国人，但我们会谈到这一点。60年代和70年代巨大的石油繁荣对伊朗来说是一个非常复杂的祝福。它造成了深刻的不平等感。农村农民和城市贫民与赢家、大都市精英之间存在明显的差距。至关重要的是，它引发了大规模的通货膨胀。所以70年代的价格每年上涨约15%。这非常像美洲征服后的西班牙，
the influx of all the silver that basically destroyed the Spanish economy. The oil money is, you know, in many ways it makes a lot of things worse as well as better. So Iran is a very young country. Amazing, the fact is this. Half the population of Iran in the 1970s was under the age of 16. So that's a lot of ambitious people. and if their ambitions aren't met, they will be very quickly frustrated. And we already mentioned the population explosion in Tehran.
所有白银的涌入基本上摧毁了西班牙经济。石油钱，你知道，在很多方面让事情变得更糟，也变得更好。所以伊朗是一个非常年轻的国家。事实是这样的：1970年代伊朗一半的人口在16岁以下。所以那有很多雄心勃勃的人。如果他们的雄心壮志得不到满足，他们很快就会感到沮丧。我们已经提到了德黑兰的人口爆炸。
So you have tens of thousands of people, hundreds of thousands, who have moved to Tehran from the countryside in search of work and they are packed into these pretty grim concrete tower blocks on the edge of the city. You mentioned the traffic. The traffic is notorious across the world. You know, you can't get anywhere. The electricity grid cannot cope with all the newcomers, so there are constant blackouts.
所以你有成千上万，几十万人，为了寻找工作从农村搬到德黑兰，他们被挤在城市边缘那些相当阴暗的混凝土塔楼里。你提到了交通。交通在世界各地都是臭名昭著的。你知道，你哪儿也去不了。电网无法应对所有的新来者，所以经常停电。
and the costs because the inflation are going up all the time. So in some parts of Tehran, rent went up 300% in five years. And there are a lot of poor, unskilled young men who have moved from the countryside who find all this utterly overwhelming and frustrating. They're struggling economically. They are shocked by what you were describing. You know, the social whirl of the people who are well off. You know, the women are revealing dresses, drinking alcohol and whatnot.
还有因为通货膨胀而不断上涨的成本。所以德黑兰的一些地区，五年内房租上涨了300%。许多从农村搬来的贫穷、缺乏技能的年轻人发现这一切让他们感到无比压抑和沮丧。他们的经济状况非常艰难。他们对你所描述的那些富人的社交圈感到震惊。你知道，那些穿着暴露、饮酒作乐等等的女性。
and they feel totally alienated from the Shah in his court. And they also feel alienated from the tens of thousands of Westerners who now live in Tehran because they are sort of participating in the boom, rather like Westerners who now live in the Middle East in Dubai or somewhere. So to quote a young woman, Masume Ebtekar, who became very prominent in the early days of the revolution and in the hostage crisis. She wrote later, Most of the Americans who lived in Iran behaved in a way that revealed their sense of self-importance and superiority.
他们对沙阿及其宫廷感到彻底的疏离。他们也对现在居住在德黑兰的数万名西方人感到疏离，因为这些人似乎正在参与这场繁荣，就像现在居住在中东迪拜或其他地方的西方人一样。引用一位年轻女性马苏梅·埃布特卡尔的话，她在革命初期和人质危机中变得非常突出。她后来写道，大多数居住在伊朗的美国人的行为方式，暴露了他们那种自以为是和优越感。
They had come to expect extra respect, even deference from all Iranians, from Shushin Boy to Shah. American lifestyles had come to be imposed as an ideal, the ultimate goal. American books, magazines, films that swept over our country like a flood and we found ourselves wandering, is there any room for our own culture? And I think this is very common in the 60s and 70s across the developing world. But it's especially pronounced in Iran, which has been transformed so much by all of this money. And which has such an ancient culture and such a distinctive culture. Of course.
他们开始期待额外的尊重，甚至是从所有伊朗人那里获得顺从，从擦鞋童到沙阿。美国的生活方式被强加为一种理想，一种终极目标。美国书籍、杂志、电影像洪水一样席卷我们的国家，我们发现自己感到迷茫，我们的文化还有生存空间吗？我认为这在60年代和70年代的发展中国家非常普遍。但在伊朗尤为明显，因为这里被这些金钱改变得太多了。而且它拥有如此古老且独特的文化。当然。
Now, it's no accident. Massimo Eptekar, the woman who wrote those words, was a student. And thanks to the Shah's modernisation project, there are now 200,000 students in Tehran and the other big cities. I mean, that's a rookie's era for a dictator, isn't it? Yeah, create this class of people, educated people, whose ambitions are not being met. Now some of them turn to socialism or communism, but most don't, because if you are feeling alienated and frustrated, given the importance the clerics have always had and the place of Islam in Iran's history, if you are looking for meaning and order and solace and all of those kinds of things, Islam offers you more authentically Iranian answers than socialism and communism do. something is brewing, you know, things are brewing in the kind of tower blocks and in the university campuses and things as the 70s continue.
这绝非偶然。写下这些话的马苏梅·埃布特卡尔当时是一名学生。多亏了沙阿的现代化项目，现在德黑兰和其他大城市有20万名学生。我的意思是，这对独裁者来说是一个菜鸟时代，不是吗？是的，创造了这样一个阶层，受过教育的人，但他们的抱负却无法实现。现在他们中的一些人转向社会主义或共产主义，但大多数人没有，因为如果你感到疏离和沮丧，考虑到教士在伊朗历史上一直拥有的重要地位和伊斯兰教的地位，如果你在寻找意义、秩序、慰藉以及所有这些东西，伊斯兰教为你提供的答案比社会主义和共产主义更具伊朗本土特色。你知道，随着70年代的继续，在那些塔楼公寓和大学校园里，某种东西正在酝酿。
But in Washington, people just don't notice this. And one reason they don't notice is if you're American, you know, you're interested in foreign policy in the early 1970s, you're not looking at Iran, you're looking at Vietnam, in Southeast Asia or Soviet Union or Eastern Europe or Cuba or something. Even in the US embassy, the staff at the US embassy, they had lots of links to the Shah's court, obviously, but not to opposition groups or to the clerics. So I mentioned William Sullivan, the ambassador. When he arrived in 1977, I mean, he wrote this really kind of caustic memoir about his time. He said, I was shocked how few of my colleagues spoke Farsi, how few of them
但在华盛顿，人们根本没有注意到这一点。他们没注意到的一个原因是，如果你是美国人，你对70年代初的外交政策感兴趣，你关注的不是伊朗，而是越南、东南亚、苏联、东欧或古巴之类的地方。即使在美国大使馆，美国大使馆的工作人员显然与沙阿的宫廷有很多联系，但与反对派团体或教士们却没有联系。所以我提到了大使威廉·沙利文。当他在1977年抵达时，他写了一篇关于他那段时光的非常尖刻的回忆录。他说，我感到震惊的是，我的同事中很少有人会说波斯语，很少有人
had ever been outside the capital. So in other words, the information that's getting back to Washington, a lot of it is wrong. And when Carter arrives, you know, the palace for that New Year's Eve dinner. He doesn't realize anything is wrong. He thinks the Shah is going to be there for decades and nothing could possibly go wrong. But actually, just a week after Carter leaves, that's when things start to kick off. Because in recent months, these tapes of Khomeini sermons have been flooding into the markets of Iran and his rhetoric is more and more ferocious. He says the Shah is a Zionist agent, a Jewish agent. He says the Shah is an American serpent. He says people should stop paying tax. They just stop going to school or university or whatever.
去过首都以外的地方。换句话说，传回华盛顿的信息中，很多都是错误的。当卡特到达时，你知道，在那个新年前夜的晚宴上。他没有意识到出了什么问题。他认为沙阿会统治几十年，不可能出任何差错。但实际上，就在卡特离开一周后，事情就开始爆发了。因为近几个月来，这些霍梅尼讲道的录音带不断涌入伊朗的市场，他的言辞越来越凶猛。他说沙阿是犹太复国主义的代理人，是犹太人的代理人。他说沙阿是美国的毒蛇。他说人们应该停止纳税。他们只是停止去学校或大学等等。
This drives the Shah mad. So he waits for Carter to leave, and on the 7th of January, he gets one of the biggest papers in Iran, Etalaat, to publish a repost. And this article, one of the most incendiary articles in any paper in any country in the world in the 20th century, is a full-blooded attack on Khomeini. It says Khomeini is a tool of red and black imperialism. What it means by that is he's been controlled both.
这让沙阿发疯了。所以他等卡特离开，在1月7日，他让伊朗最大的报纸之一《埃特拉特报》发表了一篇反驳文章。这篇文章是20世纪任何国家任何报纸中最具煽动性的文章之一，是对霍梅尼的全面攻击。它说霍梅尼是红色和黑色帝国主义的工具。它的意思是，他一直受到这两者的控制。
both by the communists and by the British. This is a fairly standard kind of theme of Iranian invective. It's good to see the British still. Yeah, it's always the British, right? So are the British black? We're the black imperialists in league with the red imperialist in Moscow. That's the Shah's thinking. This article says, Khomeini's always been into poetry.
既受共产主义者控制，也受英国人控制。这是伊朗式谩骂中相当标准的主题。很高兴看到英国人还在其中。是的，总是英国人，对吧？那么英国人是黑色的吗？我们是与莫斯科的红色帝国主义勾结的黑色帝国主义者。这就是沙阿的想法。这篇文章说，霍梅尼一直喜欢诗歌。
That's a bad sign. It is a bad sign. I mean, everyone in the CIA knows that. It's a really bad sign. It says his ancestry, he's not even really Iranian. He's actually Indian. So he's a foreigner. And it says he's typical of the class, actually.
这是一个坏兆头。这确实是个坏兆头。我的意思是，中情局的每个人都知道这一点。这真的是个坏兆头。它说他的血统，他甚至不是真正的伊朗人。他实际上是印度人。所以他是个外国人。而且它说他实际上是那个阶层的典型。
A lot of these rural clerics are, and I quote, parasites engaged in sodomy, usury, and they're drunk most of the time. So this is what this article says. And this is an absolutely catastrophic own goal. Because within hours of this article, this newspaper reaching the newsstands, there are huge protests in the city of Gom, which is the seminary city where the Ayatollah had been a student and then a teacher. and the seminar is shut down and all the religious students pour out onto the streets to sort of protest about this.
很多这些农村教士都是，我引用一下，“从事鸡奸、高利贷的寄生虫，而且他们大部分时间都在酗酒。”这就是这篇文章所说的。这是一个绝对灾难性的乌龙球。因为在这篇文章见报后的几个小时内，库姆市就爆发了大规模抗议，那是阿亚图拉曾经作为学生和老师所在的宗教城市。神学院被关闭，所有的宗教学生涌上街头进行抗议。
There were demonstrations outside the police station. The police end up firing into the crowds. There's a stampede. And then a number of people who either shot or trampled to death. So this is all January 1978.
警察局外发生了示威。警察最终向人群开火。发生了踩踏事件。然后一些人要么被枪杀，要么被踩死。所以这一切都发生在1978年1月。
Now how many people were shot or trampled to death? Reports at the time said maybe 30, 40. The historian Michael Axeworthy is written a brilliant book on the Iranian Revolution, so it's actually almost all these reports probably exaggerated and it might have been like five people.
那么有多少人被枪杀或踩死？当时的报道说可能有30到40人。历史学家迈克尔·阿克斯沃西写了一本关于伊朗革命的精彩著作，他说实际上所有这些报道可能都被夸大了，可能只有五个人左右。
It doesn't really matter though, does it? It doesn't, exactly, it doesn't matter. Because what matters is that this has happened. Of course. And now what happens is this strange cycle. After 40 days, there are meant to be memorial services for people who've died. So 40 days after these deaths,
但这并不重要，不是吗？确实，完全不重要。因为重要的是这件事已经发生了。当然。现在发生的是这种奇怪的循环。40天后，人们要为死者举行追悼会。所以这些死亡事件发生40天后，
on the 18th of February, there were these memorial services. And there are more demonstrations at universities across Iran. There's a demonstration, for example, in Tabriz, which is close to the border with Soviet Azerbaijan. There, too, the crowd kicks off. There are scuffles.
在2月18日，举行了这些追悼会。伊朗各地的大学里有更多的示威活动。例如，在大不里士发生了一场示威，那里靠近苏联阿塞拜疆的边界。在那里，人群也爆发了。发生了冲突。
There are attacks on cinemas. There are attacks on banks and the symbols of kind of Western influence. The army is sent in. More people are shot. Again, unclear exactly how many. So 40 days after that, these people have memorial services, and you have more riots. And so you have this cycle.
电影院遭到袭击。银行和西方影响的象征遭到袭击。军队被派往那里。更多人被枪杀。同样，不清楚具体有多少人。所以40天后，这些人举行了追悼会，又发生了更多的骚乱。所以就有了这个循环。
Every 40 days, there are memorial services for the people who were killed in the last sort of outbreak of rioting and there's more rioting and so there'll be more memorial services in 40 days' time. So this continues till mid-May. Now the Shah contemplating all this, he makes some concessions.
每40天，人们就会为上次骚乱中丧生的人举行追悼会，然后会有更多的骚乱，所以40天后又会有更多的追悼会。这种情况一直持续到5月中旬。现在沙阿考虑这一切，他做出了一些让步。
He thinks, well, I'll buy the protesters off. He fires the head of the secret police. He says, we can have free elections to the Iranian parliament next year. But he doesn't really get. The Shah is just as detached in many ways as the Americans are. He says, I think this is probably
他想，好吧，我会用钱收买抗议者。他解雇了秘密警察头子。他说，明年我们可以举行伊朗议会的自由选举。但他真的不明白。沙阿在很多方面和美国人一样脱离现实。他说，我想这很可能是
being masterminded by the communists and almost certainly the British. Brilliant. So we're still on the scene again. Again, this mad kind of anglophobia. Now, his courtiers are baffled why the Shah is so... The Shah seems very listless during all this.
由共产主义者策划的，几乎可以肯定是英国人。太棒了。所以我们又回到了现场。又是这种疯狂的恐英症。现在，他的朝臣们很困惑为什么沙阿如此……沙阿在这一切过程中显得非常无精打采。
He's kind of slightly disengaged. They can't understand why he hasn't cracked down much harder. And why actually he's absent from public life and he's spending a lot of his time in his palace at the Caspian Sea. And one reason for this is that what a lot of the Shah's advisors don't know is that he is actually desperately ill.
他有点心不在焉。他们无法理解为什么他没有采取更严厉的镇压措施。以及为什么他实际上缺席了公共生活，大部分时间都待在里海的宫殿里。原因之一是，许多沙阿的顾问不知道的是，他实际上病得很重。
Four years earlier he'd been swimming, he'd noticed a swelling in his side. And his doctors have brought in a French specialist who diagnosed leukemia, the Shah had leukemia. But unbelievably, the Shah's doctors didn't have the courage to tell him. They told him, oh, it's a, you've got a minor blood condition. In 1978, they still haven't really. told him. He seems completely depressed, but they've hidden from him the nature of his condition, although they have told his wife, Empress Farah. Now, there are rumours at this point spreading through Tehran. There's something wrong with the Shah. He looks really kind of gaunt. He's lost a lot of
四年前他游泳时，注意到侧腹有肿块。他的医生请来了一位法国专家，诊断出是白血病，沙阿患有白血病。但令人难以置信的是，沙阿的医生没有勇气告诉他。他们告诉他，哦，这只是一个小小的血液问题。在1978年，他们仍然没有真正告诉他。他看起来完全抑郁了，但他们对他隐瞒了他的病情性质，尽管他们告诉了他的妻子法拉皇后。现在，德黑兰流传着谣言。沙阿出了问题。他看起来真的很憔悴。他瘦了很多
weight. He seems really miserable and unhappy and in pain and so on. But even after the doctors finally tell the Shah the truth in the summer of 1978, the US Embassy is still reporting to Washington there are rumors about the Shah's health and I quote, our sources indicate there's no doubt the Russians are spreading the stories to the best of our knowledge the Shah is fine.
体重。他看起来真的很痛苦、不快乐等等。但即使在1978年夏天医生最终告诉沙阿真相后，美国大使馆仍然向华盛顿报告说有关于沙阿健康的谣言，我引用一下，“我们的消息来源表明，毫无疑问是俄国人在散布这些故事，据我们所知，沙阿很好。”
I mean, this is insane that they're still doing this. And what is more, the Pentagon and the CIA are both still telling Carter. Yes, there have been a lot of protests in Iran. Yes, there's this business with the students and whatnot.
我的意思是，他们还在这样做真是太疯狂了。而且更重要的是，五角大楼和中情局仍然都在告诉卡特。是的，伊朗有很多抗议活动。是的，有学生之类的事情。
However, the Shah is going to be fine, the regime is fine. His security forces are well capable of handling any disorder. And presumably, still at this point, there isn't really any understanding of the potential role that Islam could be playing and might play in the future. No, not at all. They regard this as student protests. The big danger is that Iran would go communist.
然而，沙阿会没事的，政权是稳固的。他的安全部队完全有能力处理任何混乱。据推测，到目前为止，人们对伊斯兰教可能发挥的作用以及未来可能发挥的作用仍然没有任何了解。不，完全没有。他们认为这只是学生抗议。最大的危险是伊朗会走向共产主义。
This is the fear whenever the Americans confront any of these kinds of things. So they're seeing it through the prism of the left-right axis. Of course. rather than of a kind of secularist Islamic access. There are some people as time goes on, Ambassador Sullivan is one of them, as 1978 wears on, who says, you know, I think we should start talking to some of these clerics to find out what they want and who they are. But, you know, famously, the CIA have profiles of all the big people in Iranian politics. They don't have one prepared for the Ayatollah Khomeini because they just don't think he's that bigger a factor. You know, they're much more interested in traditional politicians.
每当美国人面对这类事情时，这就是他们的恐惧。所以他们是通过左翼-右翼轴线的棱镜来看待它的。当然。而不是通过世俗主义-伊斯兰轴线。随着时间的推移，有些人，沙利文大使就是其中之一，随着1978年的推移，他说，你知道，我认为我们应该开始与这些教士中的一些人交谈，找出他们想要什么以及他们是谁。但是，你知道，众所周知，中情局有伊朗政治中所有大人物的档案。他们没有为阿亚图拉·霍梅尼准备一份，因为他们根本不认为他是一个那么大的因素。你知道，他们对传统的政治家更感兴趣。
So, you know, things are getting worse, not least because, because of the high inflation, the Shah's government has decided to try to drive down prices and one way they'll do that is they'll slash spending. So that summer, thousands of people are laid off and a lot of these people are young men from Tehran's working class areas. So they're angry, they're economically angry as much as anything. So then in August you get the key moment, arguably, of the whole revolution, the 19th of August. And this happens not in Tehran, but in a town called Abadan, which is in southwestern Iran,
所以，你知道，情况正在恶化，尤其是因为高通胀，沙阿政府决定试图压低价格，他们这样做的一种方式就是削减开支。所以那个夏天，成千上万的人被解雇，这些人中很多是来自德黑兰工人阶级地区的年轻人。所以他们很愤怒，他们的经济愤怒和其他任何事情一样强烈。然后在8月，你迎来了整个革命可以说最关键的时刻，8月19日。这发生在德黑兰，而是在一个叫阿巴丹的城镇，位于伊朗西南部，
on the border with Iraq. So 8 o'clock that night, the 19th of August, hundreds of people have packed into the cinema wrecks to see a very, very popular film, one of the most popular films of the 70s in Iran, called The Deer. And just after 8.20, so the film's been running for 20 minutes or so, four men barred the doors of the cinema, they poured petrol onto the doors, and then they lit the doors with a match. The doors went up. The cinema went up in flames. There was total panic inside, a massive stampede,
在与伊拉克的边界上。所以那天晚上8点，8月19日，数百人挤进了雷克斯电影院观看一部非常、非常受欢迎的电影，70年代伊朗最受欢迎的电影之一，叫《鹿》。就在8点20分之后，电影放映了20分钟左右，四名男子封锁了电影院的门，他们把汽油倒在门上，然后用火柴点燃了门。门烧了起来。电影院陷入火海。里面一片恐慌，发生了大规模踩踏事件，
and about 500 people were burned to death in this cinema. Outside Iran, almost all historians now agree this was the work of Islamic militants. So through the 70s, there'd been a series of Islamic militant attacks on symbols of westernization, on cinemas, on bars, on banks, on airline offices, things like that, and this is another of them. But in the climate of August 1978, people on the street said, do you know who did it?
大约500人在这次电影院火灾中被烧死。在伊朗境外，几乎所有历史学家现在都同意这是伊斯兰激进分子的所作所为。所以在70年代，发生了一系列伊斯兰激进分子对西方化象征的袭击，针对电影院、酒吧、银行、航空公司办公室等，这是其中之一。但在1978年8月的氛围中，街上的人们说，你知道是谁干的吗？
The Shah's secret police to try to frame Islamic militants. And that is still the official line on this fire in the Islamic Republic of Iran today. So if you go to Iran today to talk about this fire, people will say the Shah did it. So it's kind of the, it's the Iranian equivalent of the thousands locked up in sinister dungeons. in the Bastille. Yes. The myth is what matters, obviously, in a revolution, rather than in the case of French Revolution,
是沙阿的秘密警察为了陷害伊斯兰激进分子。而这仍然是今天伊朗伊斯兰共和国关于这场火灾的官方说法。所以如果你今天去伊朗谈论这场火灾，人们会说沙阿干的。所以这有点像，这是伊朗版的巴士底狱中关押的成千上万的人。是的。在革命中，神话显然比事实更重要，而不是像法国大革命那样，
the fact that there weren't barely anyone in the Bastille. Exactly. And so within days, people have poured onto the streets, hundreds of thousands of people across Iran, and they are shouting, the Shah is guilty, burn the Shah. I mean, the Shah had nothing to do with this. But from this point, I think there's no way back for him.
事实上巴士底狱里几乎没有人。没错。所以几天之内，人们涌上街头，伊朗各地成千上万的人，他们高喊着，“沙阿有罪，烧死沙阿”。我的意思是，沙阿与此毫无关系。但从这一点来看，我认为他已经没有回头路了。
So by September, there are constant demonstrations in Tehran. There are crowds chanting for Khomeini and calling for the end of the Parlelevi monarchy. In Friday the 8th of September, the Shah declares martial law. But there's a great gathering at a place called Jalais Square. It is a working class area in Tehran. The soldiers call on the crowd to disperse. They fire tear gas at them.
所以到了9月，德黑兰不断有示威活动。人群高呼霍梅尼的名字，要求结束巴列维王朝。在9月8日星期五，沙阿宣布戒严。但在一个叫贾莱广场的地方有一个大集会。那是德黑兰的一个工人阶级地区。士兵们呼吁人群散开。他们向他们发射催泪瓦斯。
Then they start firing into the crowd. There is total chaos. And by the time this is all over about 100 people have been killed. And with that, it really is downhill all the way for the Shah. There are rumors now. There are really exaggerated rumours that he had sent in helicopters and people who had been machine gunning the crowds from the helicopters. Madly, people start to say, you know, those troops who fired on the crowds,
然后他们开始向人群开火。现场一片混乱。当这一切结束时，大约有100人被杀。随之而来的是沙阿彻底的衰落。现在有谣言了。有非常夸张的谣言说他派出了直升机，有人从直升机上用机枪扫射人群。疯狂的是，人们开始说，你知道，那些向人群开火的部队，
they were actually Israeli troops. The Shah is bringing in Israeli troops as mercenaries to fire around our own people. It's a bit like, you know, the claims that Charles I was going to use soldiers from Ireland against the London apprentices in 1642 or something. And a striking illustration of the role that Israel is already playing in the demonology of Iranian militants. So we are now in the autumn of 1978. There are massive strikes across Iran. The one thing the regime fears most, the strikes have shut down the oil fields on which Iran's exports depend.
他们实际上是以色列军队。沙阿正在引入以色列军队作为雇佣兵来向我们自己的人民开火。这有点像，你知道，关于查理一世在1642年要使用来自爱尔兰的士兵对付伦敦学徒的说法。这是一个引人注目的例子，说明了以色列已经在伊朗激进分子的恶魔学中扮演的角色。所以我们现在处于1978年的秋天。伊朗各地发生了大规模罢工。政权最害怕的一件事是，罢工关闭了伊朗出口所依赖的油田。
There are crowds in the streets every day. There are attacks on banks and restaurants every day. And already in some towns in Iran, power has been taken from. from the legitimate authorities and it's been taken over by revolutionary strike committees. Now, if you're with the revolution, this is very exciting. If you're not with the revolution, it is terrifying. And in his memoirs, Ambassador William Sullivan describes standing at the US embassy and looking out through an upstairs window and he sees in the distance troops holding back demonstrators. He sees cars burning in the middle of the road. He sees smoke rising from burning
每天街上都有人群。每天都有针对银行和餐馆的袭击。而且在伊朗的一些城镇，权力已经从合法当局手中夺走，并被革命罢工委员会接管。现在，如果你支持革命，这非常令人兴奋。如果你不支持革命，那就太可怕了。威廉·沙利文大使在他的回忆录中描述了站在美国大使馆楼上的窗户向外看，他看到远处部队在阻挡示威者。他看到汽车在路中间燃烧。他看到燃烧的建筑物冒出浓烟，
buildings. And he thinks something has to change. We have to do something. So on the 9th of November, he sends a secret cable to Washington with the title, Thinking the Unthinkable. And he says, the Shah is finished. It's over. And if we don't act now, Iran, which is so vital to us, will slip out of our hands forever. He says we should ditch the Shah right now. And it may well be time to do a deal with the Ayatollah Ruhola Khomeini. What tension? What drama? So will Jimmy Carter follow that advice? Will he, as it were, get into bed with the Ayatollah, a rather unpleasant image, but Dominant that's what you've written. And we will find out next time. As the Revolution quickens, the Shah flees Iran,
他认为必须有所改变。我们必须做点什么。所以11月9日，他向华盛顿发送了一份秘密电报，标题是“思考不可想象之事”。他说，沙阿完了。结束了。如果我们现在不采取行动，对我们如此重要的伊朗将永远从我们手中溜走。他说我们现在应该抛弃沙阿。也许是时候与阿亚图拉鲁霍拉·霍梅尼达成协议了。多么紧张！多么戏剧性！那么吉米·卡特会听从那个建议吗？他会，可以说，与阿亚图拉同流合污吗？这是一个相当令人不快的形象，但Dominant，这就是你写的。我们下次会知道。随着革命加速，沙阿逃离伊朗，
Khomeini ends up returning to Tehran in triumph. And we have also had Jimmy Carter's tennis court monitoring. In our next episode, we will be revisiting the Other key fact in Carter's presidency, his fishing trip on a swamp. If you'd like to hear that and you'd like to hear all three of the episodes that are still to come in this series, then you can join our own beleaguered embassy of godless imperialists. The Rest Is History Club at the Restishistory.com. But for now, Coda hafez. Hello, Ristis History fans.
霍梅尼最终凯旋回到德黑兰。我们还经历了吉米·卡特的网球场监控。在下一集中，我们将重温卡特总统任期内的另一个关键事实，他在沼泽地的钓鱼之旅。如果你想听那个，并且想听这个系列中即将推出的所有三集，那么你可以加入我们自己被围困的无神论帝国主义者大使馆。Rest Is History俱乐部，网址是Restishistory.com。但现在，Coda hafez。你好，Rest Is History的粉丝们。
It's spy and pigeon aficionado Gordon Carrera here from the, The Rest is Classified podcast with a quick message for those of you enjoying Tom and Dominic's Iran series. A little while ago on The Rest is Classified, we did two episodes on the overthrow of Iranian Prime Minister Mohammed Mossadegh in 1953. A coup orchestrated by the CIA and MI6, it's a story full of dirty tricks, boozy spies, Iranian weightlifters and politicians in their pajamas. And it tells you a lot about how the CIA got the taste for regime change. So tune in to episodes one and two of The Rest is Classified to hear the full story. One of the darkest scandals of the modern era. A billionaire financier. Powerful
我是间谍和鸽子爱好者戈登·卡雷拉，来自《Rest is Classified》播客，给那些正在享受汤姆和多米尼克伊朗系列节目的听众发个简短信息。不久前在《Rest is Classified》上，我们做了两集关于1953年推翻伊朗总理穆罕默德·摩萨台的节目。这是一场由中情局和军情六处策划的政变，故事充满了肮脏的伎俩、醉醺醺的间谍、伊朗举重运动员和穿着睡衣的政客。它告诉你很多关于中情局是如何对政权更迭产生兴趣的。所以请收听《Rest is Classified》的第一集和第二集，听听完整的故事。现代史上最黑暗的丑闻之一。一位亿万富翁金融家。强大的
friends. Hidden networks. And questions that refuse to go away. Was Jeffrey Epstein a spy? I'm Gordon Carrera. And I'm David McCloskey. And we're the hosts of The Rest is Classified, the Intelligence and National Security podcast from Gollhanger. And we've just released a gripping new series investigating whether Epstein was linked to any spy agencies. And asking what those agencies might have known about him. Listen or watch now on Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
朋友。隐藏的网络。以及那些挥之不去的问题。杰弗里·爱泼斯坦是间谍吗？我是戈登·卡雷拉。我是大卫·麦克洛斯基。我们是来自Gollhanger的情报和国家安全播客《Rest is Classified》的主持人。我们刚刚发布了一个引人入胜的新系列，调查爱泼斯坦是否与任何间谍机构有联系。并询问这些机构可能对他了解多少。现在就在Spotify、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方收听或观看。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。